Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich sage, hallo hier zur 31. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe, in der wir immer wieder auf die verschiedensten Arten und Weisen in das wissenschaftliche Feld hineinstochern. Und heute wollen wir uns ein zweites Mal dem Feld der Mathematik nähern. Wir hatten das schon in Ausgabe Nummer 26, mit dem ausführlichen Gespräch über die Geschichte von Gottfried Wilhelm Leibniz mit Eberhard Knoblauch, wo wir mal ein wenig in die Geschichte eingestiegen sind und dieses Porträt geliefert haben. Heute geht es eher um einen etwas generelleren Ansatz. Mathematik ist so oder so hier im Fokus und vielleicht auch ein wenig Geometrie und zunächst einmal begrüße ich unseren Gesprächspartner heute, nämlich Günther Ziegler, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herzlich willkommen bei Forschergeist. Ja Herr Ziegler, Sie sind Mathematiker an der FU in Berlin, Institut für Mathematik, das beschreibt das schon mal ganz richtig oder?
Das ist eine relativ kompakte Zusammenfassung für eine sehr vielfältige Tätigkeit und ein riesiges Gebiet ja.
Wie groß ist denn der Bereich an der FU?
Also an der FU, das Institut hat glaube ich 14 Professuren laut Strukturplan, ist letztlich sehr viel größer. Ist dann deswegen noch sehr viel größer, weil die Berliner Mathematik eigentlich zusammengehört. Also das sind drei große mathematische Institute von TU, HU und FU. Da gehören zwar Forschungsinstitute dazu, das ZUSE-Institut und das Weierstraß-Institut. Da gehören Projekte dazu, wie das Matheon, Forschungszentrum Mathematik für Schlüsseltechnologien, die Berlin Mathematical-School ist unsere gemeinsame Graduierten-Schule, die mir selber sehr am Herzen liegt und wo ich sehr aktiv drin unterwegs bin. Also insofern ist Mathematik in Berlin ein weites Feld, wie Effie Briests Vater sagen würde.
Ein weites Feld. Das heißt der Mathematik wird zumindest in Berlin ein großer Stellenwert eingeräumt, kann das man das so sagen?
Ja, ich glaube Mathematik ist in Berlin eine sehr zentrale Wissenschaftsdisziplin.
Jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt, und das ist auch gut so. Das ist dann sozusagen ein modernes Zitat, aber in der Tat schon immer gewesen. Und die Berlin-Brandenburgische Akademie hat Gottfried Wilhelm Leibniz gegründet, der also da sozusagen für die Mathematik in Berlin eben auch zentral ist und dieses Jahr 370. Geburtstag und 300. Todestag hat. Also eben auch gefeiert wird in Berlin. Und anderswo, Euler mindestens genauso wichtig für die Mathematik, eben auch in Berlin. Also einer der ganz Großen der Mathematik mit seinen Entdeckungen, mit seinen Perspektiven. Also auch so wie wir heute Mathematik machen. Die Notation, da ist ein ordentliches Stück Leibniz drin und sehr viel Euler.
Schon immer gewesen?
Euler hat irgendwann mal angefangen, die Kreiszahl also statt P dann ein Pi dafür zu schreiben und seitdem schreiben wir Pi für die Kreiszahl.
Bevor wir vielleicht mal auf die Geschichte der Mathematik noch ein bisschen näher eingehen, vielleicht zunächst einmal Ihre Geschichte. Ich habe so ein bisschen die Vermutung, Mathematik hat schon relativ früh im Leben eine Rolle gespielt oder nicht?
Also Mathematik hat für mich schon relativ früh eine Rolle gespielt ja. Wobei das was da dann Mathematik heißt nicht das ist was mich heute umtreibt. Aber ich erinnere mich sozusagen als Fünfjähriger an Autofahrten, wo Mama den Jungen sozusagen, um ihn zu beschäftigen, mit Rechenaufgaben versorgt hat, wenn die Autofahrten sehr lang war. Ich habe dann in der Grundschule die 3. Klasse übersprungen aus unterschiedlichen Gründen und musste dafür irgendwie einen Eignungstest machen, wo die eben einfach feststellen wollten, ob der Junge das eigentlich schaffen kann oder ob das nur übereifrige Eltern sind, die den Kleinen überfordern. Der Test war glaube ich okay, nur in Rechnen oder in Mathe sah es nicht gut aus. Und damals hat Mama denen gesagt, macht euch keine Sorgen, der Junge kann das. Und an dem Nachmittag, wo der Brief dann kam, dass ich in die 4. Klasse soll ab nächste Woche, statt der 3. Klasse, da hat sie mir dann erst mal das schriftlich dividieren beigebracht, weil man das eben einfach braucht in der 4. Klasse und ich das noch nicht konnte.
Hat die Mutter denn auch schon so eine gewisse mathematische Ader gehabt oder waren das einfach nur die Grundkenntnisse?
Also meine Eltern waren beide stolz auf die 1 in Mathe im Abitur, aber meine Mutter ist ein Sprachengenie. Und die hat dann nach dem Abitur, wo man immer damals behauptet hat, Lehrer braucht man nicht, was damals falsch war und heute genauso falsch ist, hat sie dann als Dolmetscherin und Übersetzerin studiert Französisch und Englisch. Und ist dann unter anderem dann 1,5 Jahre als Stewardess für PAA, also die spätere Pan Am auf der Welt unterwegs gewesen. Und hat seitdem irgendwie ein knappes Dutzend weitere Sprachen gelernt. Beeindruckt mich immer, ist nicht mein Talent. Also sie war jetzt nicht mathematisch unterwegs.
Und wie ging es dann weiter mit der Mathematik? Oder war das jetzt sozusagen schon das Dividieren von Hand lernen ausreichen?
Beim schriftlichen Dividieren hat es nicht aufgehört, sonst hätte ich es auch nicht zum Matheprofessor gebracht, denke ich mal. Mich haben eigentlich die Mathewettbewerbe angefixt. Also als Schüler irgendwann 9. Klasse aus in der Tat irgendeinem Gespräch meiner Mutter als Elternbeiratsvorsitzenden mit Frau Treitwein, einer Mathe- und Physik-Lehrerin, kam dann der Hinweis auf den Bundeswettbewerb Mathematik und da habe ich seit der 9. Klasse teilgenommen, jedes Jahr wieder und eine Menge gelernt. Meinen Ehrgeiz kultiviert und sozusagen diese Mathewettbewerbe habe ich sehr viel gelernt und hatte ich natürlich auch den Ansatz, ich will mir zeigen und denen zeigen, dass ich das kann. Und sozusagen in fünf aufeinanderfolgenden Jahren jedes Mal weiter gekommen. Letzten beiden Jahren dann eben auch gewonnen. Das war für mich wichtig vom Lernen her, aber auch für die Motivation und auch mit den anderen Wettbewerben Jugend forscht, Mathematikolympiade und so war dann am Ende klar, nach dem Abi studieren.
Und ich habe dann so ein bisschen zwischen Mathe und Physik geschwankt und dann erst mal beides studiert und dann festgestellt, die Mathematik liegt mir noch mehr und die Physik ist nicht hilfreich für die Art Mathematik, die ich machen will, also war es dann rein Mathe ab irgendeinem Zeitpunkt.
Der Bundeswettbewerb Mathematik ist ja auch vom Stifterverband ins Leben gerufen, gibt es glaube ich seit 1970. Was muss man denn da machen? Also wie fühlt man sich denn da sozusagen als Schüler, wenn man da mit einbezogen wird. Hat man das komplett in der Schule gemacht oder musste man dazu irgendwo hin?
Nein die Idee vom Bundeswettbewerb ist eigentlich, dass das Aufgaben sind, die mit Schulstoff zu schaffen sind. Das ist im Prinzip ein Einzelkämpferwettbewerb in gewisser Hinsicht. Da haben sie inzwischen auch die Regeln geändert. Aber zu meiner Zeit war das so, dass eben in der ersten Runde gab es drei oder vier Aufgaben zu bearbeiten. Man hat drei Monate Zeit, hat die also zu Hause liegen, denkt immer wieder drüber nach, versucht das zu machen, versucht das zu lösen, versucht das dann ordentlich aufzuschreiben.
Drei Monate?
Drei Monate. Also sozusagen mit Zeit, was gut ist, weil man dann eben auch nachdenken kann, ausprobieren kann und aber nach den drei Monaten muss man es dann eben wirklich im Kasten haben, in dem Fall eben im Briefkasten und schickt die Lösungen ein und wenn das richtig oder fast alles ganz richtig war, dann geht es in die zweite Runde und die ist dann eben nochmal drei Aufgaben, wieder Zeit zwei oder drei Monate und die sind dann schon schwerer. Und die dritte Runde ist dann ein Aufnahmegespräch in die Studienstiftung und das ist sozusagen gekoppelt an den Bundessieg. Also in dem Fall an Klausurwettbewerb, eben nicht Klausur, sondern ein Take Home Wettbewerb mit Zeit für die Aufgaben, wo man dann eben ausprobieren kann, wo man eben auch die Beweisschemata an den Aufgaben lernt. Ich habe eben daran wirklich gelernt, wie eine vollständige Induktion funktioniert, wie ein Beweis auf Widerspruch funktioniert.
Diese ganzen Argumentationsmethoden, die man eben eigentlich als Mathematiker dann am Ende sozusagen im Blut haben muss oder in den Knochen oder wo auch immer, wo man am Ende nicht mehr drüber nachdenkt, wie das funktioniert, das muss man sich ja alles mal beigebracht und verinnerlicht haben. Und da war das für mich ein wunderbares Trainingsfeld dann dafür.
Also ein sinnvoller Wettbewerb?
Ich finde es sehr sinnvoll, aber man darf so was immer nicht allein stellen. Ich glaube dieses sozusagen an Aufgaben sitzen zu Hause am Schreibtisch oder auf dem Sofa ist eben eine Methode Mathematik zu machen und das ist auch nur eine bestimmte Art von Mathematik. Am Ende ist Mathematik eben nicht nur Knobelaufgaben mit einer wohldefinierten Lösung, wie sie einem da vorgesetzt werden. Und es gibt ja eben auch andere Wettbewerbe, also zum Beispiel die Mathematikolympiaden sind eben Klausurwettbewerbe, wo man dann innerhalb von drei Stunden die Lösungen abliefern muss, das ist dann schon wieder ganz was anderes. Es gibt es Gruppenwettbewerbe, was wichtig ist, weil am Ende eben Mathematik Teamwork ist und heutzutage, wenn wir in der Forschung vorankommen wollen, dann ist es sehr eben Kombination von Talenten, von Perspektiven, von Ideen und sehr wenige von meinen Aufsätzen, die ich heute schreibe, sind Aufsätze, die ich alleine schreibe.
Sondern ich habe ganz wunderbare Koautoren und Kollegen, mit denen ich arbeite. Ich habe Doktoranden und Doktorandinnen, wo wir gemeinsam Dinge entwickeln, Ideen entwickeln, Dinge zusammensetzen. Und dieses  das Mathe was großes ist, wo wir gemeinsam dran arbeiten, ist was, was man nicht aus diesen Wettbewerben lernen kann.
Was lernt man denn in der Schule? Also wenn man sich jetzt mit solchen Wettbewerben auseinandersetzt, dann ist man ja im Prinzip von dem normalen Schulstoff schon ziemlich weit entfernt. Also Sie sagten gerade, es basiert auf dem, was man in der Schule lernt. Aber man wird ja dann auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise sensibilisiert. Findet man sich dann sozusagen im normalen Mathematikunterricht überhaupt noch wieder oder rutscht man da die ganze Zeit unruhig von einer auf die andere Backe?
Naja diese Mathematikwettbewerbe haben als Ausgangsmaterial sozusagen als Bauklötzchen eben doch die Dinge, die man im Mathematikunterricht macht. Und das heißt das sind dann Geometrieaufgaben über Dreiecke und Vierecke. Das ist die Zahlentheorie mit den natürlich Zahlen und Teilbarkeit und insofern ist das schon sozusagen der Stoff, wie er eben in den bundesdeutschen Sekundarschulen im Lehrplan steht. Was mich dran bisschen stört und beunruhigt und umtreibt ist, dass das eigentlich nur ein sehr kleiner und ich glaube ein sehr langweiliger Ausschnitt ist von dem, was nach meiner Überzeugung und Wahrnehmung eigentlich Mathematik ist. Also ein Thema, was mich umtreibt, ist die Frage, was ist Mathematik?
Und dann schaut man rein in die Definition, die mit Sekundarstufenlehrplänen gegeben ist und dann sag ich aus heutiger Perspektive, oh Gott ist das langweilig. Und am Ende können es doch nicht die Dreiecke sein und auch nicht die Teilbarkeit und die Zahlen alleine. Sondern Mathematik ist so was riesiges und vielfältiges und relevantes, also das ist eigentlich aus dem Lehrplanstoff nicht sichtbar. Das heißt ich glaube man lernt sehr nützliche Dinge im Mathematikunterricht und das was da an Bauklötzchen eben zur Verfügung steht, sind natürlich auch die Fundamente von dem, worauf dann alles andere aufbaut. Aber schon im Matheunterricht in der Schule müsste eigentlich sehr viel mehr von dem sichtbar werden, was dann Mathe am Ende wirklich ist.
Also irgendwie der Bezug zwischen dem, was wir in der Schule rechnen können, und was ist denn eigentlich ein Wetterbericht? Also ein Wetterbericht ist doch was, was mathematisch ausgerechnet wird. Die Theorie für die Rechnungen, die dann am Ende zu einem korrekten, zutreffenden Wetterbericht führen, ist natürlich gigantisch und kompliziert und umfassend und so weiter, aber ich glaube, man kann in der Schule sehr viel mehr davon herzeigen, man kann da mehr erzählen, man kann da mehr illustrieren von dem, was eben eigentlich Wetterbericht macht. Auch davon, warum Wetterbericht so schwierig ist, warum das so eine gigantische Aufgabe ist, was dann letztlich eben auch heißt, dass er manchmal und oft eben einfach auch nicht stimmt. Das ist aber sozusagen der Einsatz von mathematischen Methoden im Alltag, so wie wir das jeden Tag erfahren. Und es müsste irgendeinen Bezug haben zu dem, was wir im Matheunterricht dann am Ende eben auch lehren und lernen in der 8. Klasse.
Das scheint mir so ein bisschen so ein Klassiker zu sein, diese Frage, wie gestaltet  man Mathematik in der Schule so, dass es auf Interesse stößt. Und diese Frage, wozu brauch ich denn das? Und muss ich das denn lernen? Und ich werde ja später nur Straßenbahn fahren und keine Ahnung, welche Lebensentwürfe die einzelnen dann so mit sich bringen. Manchen erschließt sich das mehr oder weniger so, andere haben irgendwie so eine Grundliebe vielleicht auch dem logischen Denken und dem Rätsel entschlüsseln, aber auch ich habe immer so den Eindruck gehabt, man könnte doch mehr Türen öffnen. Wie stellt sich denn die Mathematik aus Ihrer Perspektive so in der Schule dar? Also wie erläutert man oder wie sollte man erläutern, was Mathematik ist und ausmacht? Also das Wetterberichtbeispiel war schon ein Hinweis.
Ich glaube es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche Motivationen, am Ende Mathematik zu mögen und Mathematik gut zu finden und Mathematik zu wollen, die sich dann auch auf unterschiedliche Aspekte und Teile von Mathematik beziehen. Und die die eben einfach sozusagen den Ehrgeiz haben zu knobeln und Probleme zu lösen und so weiter, die werden dann vielleicht über die Mathematikwettbewerbe reingezogen. Aber Mathe ist so viele verschiedene Sachen, das ist ein riesiger Abenteuerspielplatz und ich habe mal gesagt, man müsste eigentlich Schulfach Mathematik in der Schule ersetzen durch drei Schulfächer Mathematik. Wobei das erste Schulfach eigentlich das kann man dann mit dem Deutsch- oder Geschichtsunterricht kombinieren, Mathe einfach als Teil unserer Kultur. Also Mathematik steht am Anfang der Kultur. Es gibt mathematische Steinritzungen und Knochen und was weiß ich, lange bevor irgendjemand mit Schrift angefangen hat und quer durch die Kulturgeschichte begleitet die Mathematik als ein wesentlicher Aspekt.
Und Mathematik als Teil der Kultur wäre Schulfach eins. Schulfach zwei ist Mathematik als Handwerkszeug. Die Mathematik, die wir alle können müssen, um im Alltag zu bestehen heutzutage. Da ist die Wahrheit doch die, dass Sie vermutlich schon lange nicht mehr eine quadratische Gleichung gelöst haben nach der PQ-Formel oder Mitternachtsformel oder wie auch immer das heißt, weil Sie das im Alltag mussten. Also auch an der Supermarktkasse, um zu überschlagen, was los ist, also brauchen wir eigentlich keine quadratischen Gleichungen. Aber was wir im Alltag brauchen in der Tat ist Rechnen mit kleinen und größeren Zahlen, schon um die Zeitung zu verstehen, müssen wir am Ende eben doch wissen und ein Gefühl dafür haben, was eine Milliarde ist, wie Prozentsätze funktionieren. Also da ist schon eine ganze Menge mathematisches Handwerkszeug, Sprachfähigkeit, um Zeitung lesen und verstehen zu können, um mit argumentieren zu können.
Um dann am Ende eben auch zu merken, dass ein Lohnabschluss mit 3% Steigerung gültig auf zwei Jahre so beeindruckend nicht ist, weil das eigentlich weniger als 1,5% pro Jahr ist, also da brauchen wir Prozentsätze. Also das was man da eigentlich für den Alltag können muss, steht alles in diesem wunderbaren kleinen Lehrbuch von Adam Ries 1522. Ist insofern auch keine neue Mathematik. Was da nicht drin steht ist in der Tat die Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung, die ist erst später entdeckt und entwickelt worden. Also das muss man zu Adam Ries noch dazu nehmen. Und Schulfach zwei ist eben einfach sozusagen die Mathe als Werkzeugkasten lernen was man braucht, um da zu bestehen. Und Mathe drei ist dann Mathematik als Wissenschaft kennenlernen und das aus der Wissenschaft eben in den Griff kriegen, was man dann eben zum Beispiel braucht, um studierfähig zu sein.
Und einer der heute also jetzt nicht nur Mathe oder Physik oder Naturwissenschaften studieren will, sondern auch jemand, der Ingenieur werden will oder Arzt oder Medizin studieren und so weiter, braucht eigentlich eine solide Ausbildung in Mathematik als Wissenschaft. Eben auch in den Argumentationsmustern von Mathematik als Wissenschaft. Und ich denke, die die eben in der Oberstufe Mathe besser gelernt haben und da mehr gelernt habe, und ich sage mal so Dinge wie Aussagelogik in den Griff bekommen haben, die sind am Ende auch die besseren Richter und die besseren Verteidiger. Also das ist für den Juristen genauso wie für den Ingenieur einfach wichtig, Mathematik drei kompetent gelernt  zu haben.
Also ich zünde immer von Zeit zu Zeit noch eine Kerze für Pythagoras an, auch wenn ich ihn nicht oft aus dem Schubfach heraushole, aber das halte ich für nachvollziehbar.
Also ich erinnere mich an den einen Moment vor ein paar Jahren, wo ich wirklich den Pythagoras im Alltag gebraucht habe. Wo wir auf dem Dachboden meiner Schwiegermutter versucht haben, weil sie umgezogen war, eben einen Schrank da reinzuwuchten, und dann festgestellt haben, um diesen komischen Schrank aufzustellen, der glaube ich 90 cm breit und 1,20 m hoch war, müssen wir ihn hochkippen. Und dann war die Frage, ist die Decke denn eigentlich hoch genug, um das Ding da hochzuwuchten. Und dann ist die Frage, wie groß ist denn die Diagonale, wenn der 90 breit und 1,20 hoch ist. Und ich erinnere die Zahl noch deswegen, weil das eben das Verhältnis 3:4 ist, 90:120, so dass man wirklich im Kopf sagen kann, Pythagoras sagt, rechtwinkliges Dreieck mit Seitenlänge 3 und 4 hat Diagonale 5. Also brauchen wir da 1,50 in der Höhe.
Also das ist einmal Pythagoras im Alltag, das ist selten, aber dass wir einfach wissen, dass wenn wir sozusagen Abstände im Raum, also auch die Diagonale von einem Fußballfeld, abschätzen, dass da der Pythagoras dahintersteht, dass der Pythagoras eben uns sozusagen ganz wesentliche Dinge in der Geometrie sagt. Das ist vielleicht praktisch nicht oft nötig, wirklich selber zu rechnen, aber dass zu wissen ist natürlich ein Teil der Grundbildung, der meiner Meinung nach sehr viel elementarer ist als die Frage, wer denn dieser Goethe war.
Ja also wir haben jetzt Mitte Juni 2016, parallel läuft gerade die Fußball Europameisterschaft der Herren und da sind Laufwege und Passwege sicher auch kein ummathematisches Thema.
Ja und der Weg durch die Diagonale ist kürzer als der Weg am Rand entlang, das ist die sogenannte Dreiecksungleichung, die hat jeder Stürmer in den Beinen, insbesondere wenn er seine Mathe nicht gut kann.
Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal tatsächlich noch ein wenig auf die Geschichte. Also ich hatte ja mit Herrn Knoblauch schon anfangs erwähnt, in der 26. Ausgabe mal einen Blick auf Leibniz geworfen, einfach auch hier mal ein Blick auf individuelle Persönlichkeiten, Forschergeister auch werfen wollten. Dabei wurde schon klar, er hatte ja viel zu erzählen, wie viele Dimensionen das alles umgibt. Aber wenn wir jetzt mal einfach nur die Mathematik als solche betrachten und an den Anfang gehen, wo ist denn der Menschheit sozusagen Mathematik gewahr geworden? Also ich war vor ein paar Wochen das erste Mal im Heinz Nixdorf Forum, ich glaube dem deutschen größten Computermuseum oder zumindest dem größten Museum, was ausschließlich dem Thema gewidmet ist in Paderborn.
Und auch dort wird halt im Prinzip genau dort angefangen. Also quasi die Digitalisierung, das Niederschreiben von Mengen in Knochensteinen, anderen Objekten, um einfach Handel auszuprägen und überhaupt sozusagen da auch eine Kommunikation überhaupt erst zu ermöglichen, die dann ja auch eine Vorstufe zur Schrift geworden ist. So dass sich quasi aus diesen Zahlennotizen letzten Endes auch die Schrift und damit eben auch so unsere gesamte Textkommunikation entwickelt hat.
Also das ist die Annahme, dass möglicherweise das Rechnen vor dem Schreiben kommt sozusagen kulturhistorisch. Das ist allemal plausibel. Also das älteste Fundstück, was wir wohl haben, ist der sogenannte Ishango-Knochen. Der ist vor rund 22.000 Jahren in Zentralafrika am Ufer des Eduardsees in einem Ort entstanden, wo der Ishango-Fluss in den See einmündet, der dann von einem Vulkan verschüttet worden ist und das ist Mitte der 50er Jahre des 20. Jahrhunderts wieder ausgegraben worden. Und dieser Ishango-Knochen ist ein kleiner, 10 cm langer Knochen, der Ritzungen drin hat, die man eigentlich als Zahlen interpretieren muss. In einer von diesen drei Reihen von Ritzungen liest man dann ab die Zahlen 11, 13, 17, 19. Jeder der das sieht muss eigentlich an Primzahlen denken, das sind die Primzahlen zwischen 10 und 20.
Und dann muss man sich natürlich überlegen, ist das eigentlich plausibel, dass das Primzahlen sind und die Antwort ist, ja natürlich sind es Primzahlen, aber die Leute, die das damals geritzt haben, die können eigentlich nicht wissen, dass Primzahlen waren, weil wenn es damals noch keine Schrift gab offenbar, auch keine entwickelten Zahlensysteme. Also die 11 ist da wirklich notiert mit 11 Kerben nebeneinander. Also noch nicht das Binärsystem für den Computer.
Sondern Unärsystem.
Und wenn da sozusagen 11 Ritzungen nebeneinander sind, dann haben die Leute damals vielleicht Addition verstanden, dass wenn ich da 11 und dann 13 Dinge ritze, dass das dann 24 Kerben sind, aber noch nicht eine Multiplikation, also kann es noch nicht Primzahlen gewesen sein, aber es kann eine Art von Kalender gewesen sein. Und es ist eine Notation von Zahlen wirklich am Anfang der Kultur, in diesem sozusagen frühzeitigen Fundstück aus irgendsoeiner Art von Pompeji, also wirklich unter Vulkanasche konservierte Kultur. Und das ist sozusagen der Ausgangspunkt, das erste Fundstück. Schrift kommt erst viele tausend Jahre später.
Ja 20.000 Jahre alt ist dieser Knochen voraussichtlich.
Ja so 22.000 ist die Schätzung. Das ist natürlich alles sehr schwer zu schätzen. Dieser Jean de Heinzelin, belgischer Geologe, der das ausgegraben hat, der hat es damals auf 8-9.000 Jahre geschätzt. Das sind dann spätere Datierungen, Radiokarbonmethode und so weiter. Das ist dann Physik und Chemie schlagen dann zu, einfach in einem Versuch, festzustellen wie alt denn diese Dinge wirklich sind. Aber es ist lange vor den Hochkulturen an Euphrat und Tigris und später dann bei den Griechen.
Und man kann sagen, die Digitalisierung hat quasi vor 20.000 Jahren begonnen?
Kann man sagen, weil wir damals schon Zahlen sozusagen in Digits notieren mussten, weil wir es anders natürlich auch nicht kannten.
Außer halt den Digits, also den Fingern, wo der Begriff ja herkommt. Also im Prinzip diese abstrakte Denken, diese Wählbarkeit der Welt und damit eben so diese abstrakte Wahrnehmung, die Unterscheidung in Dingen und Größenordnungen ist quasi kann man fast sagen auch ein bisschen die Geburt einer modernen Intelligenz oder greife ich da schon zu weit?
Ja ich glaube da fängt moderne Intelligenz an. Ich meine, das ist in dem Fall ja kombiniert mit diesen Fundstücken, die durchaus auch was künstlerisches haben. Also dieser Ishango-Knochen ist am Ende mit einem Kristall verziert. Das Ding kann irgendwie auch Werkzeug oder Kunstwerk gewesen sein. Und das ist jetzt Steinzeit, das ist jetzt sicher nicht der moderne Mensch, aber es sind sicher in gewisser Hinsicht intelligente Menschen, die diese Werkzeuge geschaffen haben und als einen Schirm hier jetzt irgendwas gezählt haben mit Kerben, die am Ende eben nur Kerben sind und da kommt dann irgendwann der abstrakte Zählbegriff, der eben sagt, 10 ist dieselbe 10, wenn ich da 10 Finger oder 10 Kerben auf einem Knochen habe. Und ich glaube der abstrakte Zählbegriff ist vielleicht auch der Anfang von Kultur und der Anfang von Wissenschaft.
Wie ging es dann weiter mit der Geschichte? Wann hat sich denn so sagen wir mal dieses Feld der Mathematik als solches überhaupt erst gebildet? Weil bis dahin war das ja sozusagen einfach Teil der Kultur und kein separater.
Wir müssen natürlich zugeben, dass wir gar nicht wissen, wie es wirklich weiterging, weil Geschichte eben auch der Mathematik erst da ordentlich stattfinden kann, wo eben Geschichte geschrieben wird und wo es dann eben auch Schrift gibt. Ich bin auch kein Experte jetzt sozusagen für die alten historischen Dinge. Es lässt sich sehr viele rekonstruieren aus mesopotamischen Steintafeln und ägyptischen Papyri und so weiter. Mathematik als Wissenschaft ist der gigantische Startpunkt, den wir haben. Euklid ist mehr als 300 vor Christus, die Elemente, die letztlich ein Lehrbuch der Mathematik waren. Also den Wissensstand im antiken Griechenland zusammengefasst haben. Ob dieser Euklid jetzt wirklich eine einzelne Person war oder ob da mehrere mitgearbeitet haben glaube ich können wir heute auch nicht mehr mit Bestimmtheit sagen.
Aber diese Elemente des Euklid haben Mathematik als Wissenschaft definiert. Da war dann also plötzlich dieser systematische Aufbau mit Grundannahmen, Axiomen, Definitionen, Theoremen, Hilfssätzen, Lemmas und so weiter, also der Aufbau von Mathematik als Wissenschaft ist bei Euklid drin. Dann sind die grundlegenden Dinge der Zahlentheorie drin, die grundlegende Geometrie der Ebene ist drin und die Konstruktionen von geometrischen Körpern ist drin, also Raumgeometrie. Euklids Elemente enden mit der Klassifikation der platonischen Körper, also der fünf regelmäßigen Polyeder im dreidimensionalen Raum. Tetraeder, Würfel, Oktaeder, Dodekaeder und Ikosaeder. Eben auch mit der Gewissheit, dass es keine weiteren von diesen Objekten gibt.
Das ist sozusagen der Schlusspunkt von Euklid und das ist eine Glanzleistung von griechischer Mathematik und griechischer Geometrie und Euklid ist als Lehrbuch bis ich glaube ins 17. Jahrhundert dann verwendet worden. Also für fast 2000 Jahre. Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel in das Geometriebuch von Albrecht Dürer 1525 reinliest, dann sagt Dürer, wer seinen Euklid gelernt hat, der kann die ersten zwei Kapitel auch gleich mal überspringen. Dürer, der also Geometrie beibringen wollte den Künstlern und den Architekten, der dann, wie viele andere auch, alle auf Euklid gebaut haben. Also insofern ist Euklid für mich der antike Gigant, auch wenn wir ihn als Person nicht wirklich greifen können.
Aber und das finde ich jetzt das Interessante, jetzt ist sozusagen Mathematik auch eine Wissenschaft. Jetzt ist es sozusagen auch die Basis für andere Wissenschaften geworden.
Richtig, also mit Euklid beginnt Mathematik als Wissenschaft eben auch mit Präzision und Strenge, mit einem systematischen Aufbau, mit der Unterscheidung von Definition und Theorem und so weiter. Und eben auch mit den Beweisen, also was es vor Euklid gibt. Also es sind diese Rechnungen auf Tontafeln oder Papyri, aber rechnen kann man vieles, rechnen ist noch nicht Wissenschaft. Aber das bei Euklid das ist Wissenschaft. Und Euklid definiert dann die Primzahlen und beweist, dass es unendlich viele Primzahlen gibt. Den Beweis würden wir heute anders aufschreiben, aber es ist ein ewig gültiger Beweis und eben auch ein Modell eines Beweises.
Und im Prinzip hat ja die Mathematik als Wissenschaft damit dann eigentlich auch der Wissenschaft als solcher überhaupt erst den Weg geebnet. Wir hatten ja hier auch schon ein paar Gespräche zu Wissenschaftsgeschichte und dabei eben auch klargemacht, dass ja eigentlich auch diese Vorstellung von wie wir sie heute haben von Wissenschaft als solcher eigentlich noch ein relativ neues Ding ist, das ja auch lange Zeit das eben so wie Euklid und seine Nachfolger dann in der Antike oft einfach auch so Universalgelehrte waren, Philosophen auf jeden Fall auch. Weil das ja auch etwas mit Weltbetrachtung an sich zu tun hat. Bis sich überhaupt erst so ein Berufsbild und so ein Forscherbild herausgebildet hat, dass man sagen kann, ich mach jetzt auch nichts anderes, ich schaffe einfach Wissen und schaffe mir dann auch die entsprechenden Institutionen. Auch hier scheint ja die Mathematik dann im Prinzip die Grundlage dafür überhaupt erst gelegt zu haben. Keine Physik ohne Mathematik.
Ja keine Physik ohne Mathematik ist sicher richtig, wobei eigentlich diese Trennung zwischen Mathematik und Physik auch eine neue Entwicklung ist. Also bei Euklid glaube ich gehören Mathematik und Logik und Philosophie noch völlig zusammen. Wobei Philosophie natürlich auch Philosophie der Welt und insofern Naturphilosophie ist. In der Neuzeit 16.-19. Jahrhundert gehörten Mathematik und Physik nicht nur zusammen, sondern das war zu einem großen Teil eigentlich eine Wissenschaft. Und die Analysis zum Beispiel ist ja entworfen worden und entwickelt worden, um physikalische Probleme zu lösen und diese Verschränkung zwischen physikalischen Fragestellungen und mathematischen Theoriebildungen gehört zusammen.
Und das ist was, was sozusagen in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte einfach gar nicht zu trennen ist. Was heutzutage, wo wir sozusagen aus der Schule gewohnt sind die Wissenschaft wie im Stundenplan aufzuteilen, wo Mathe, Physik, Chemie, Biologie eben einfach getrennte Fächer sind, das ist eigentlich sozusagen eine Tendenz des 20. Jahrhunderts, dann eben auch jede Wissenschaft auf ihre eigenen Füße zu stellen und das ist natürlich auch eine sehr große Leistung für die Mathematik, solide Fundamente zu bauen, die jetzt unabhängig sind von physikalischer Intuition oder physikalischem Wissen. Aber in der Entwicklung raus gehören Mathematik und Physik zusammen und bei Leibniz und Newton und Euler und vielen von den Großen des 18. Jahrhunderts ist das immer noch die Verschränkung von Mathematik und Physik.
Und vielen anderen Sachen. Also bei Newton zum Beispiel sehr viel Alchemie auch, wo der glaube ich einen ordentlichen Teil seiner Zeit drauf verbracht hat.
Gold zu brauen.
Gold zu brauen, ja ich meine das ist sozusagen ein Nebenteil der Wissenschaftsgeschichte. Ich meine da kann man sich andere Leute auch anschauen. Wenn man sich die Werke von Kepler anschaut, Kepler hat ganz wesentliches in der Mathematik geleistet, aber von seinen astronomischen Sachen ist da eine große Menge Unsinn drin eigentlich. Der immer versucht hat, die Radien der Planetenbahnen mit Polyederdurchmessern zu erklären, was einfach eigentlich nicht funktionieren kann. Also das ist …
Aber auch ein blindes Huhn findet mal ein Korn.
Das sicher nicht. Also Kepler war sicher genial und Kepler war sicher auch ein ganz wichtiger Gelehrter und hat eben auch tolle Sachen geleistet, aber in anderen Bereichen ist er dann eben einfach auch völlig daneben gelegen und vielleicht ist es auch eine Ermutigung für uns heute, dass also auch sozusagen die großen Heroen der Geistesgeschichte und der Naturwissenschaften und auch der Mathematik in ordentlichen Teilen auch mal ordentlich daneben gelegen haben, Fehler gemacht haben, Dinge völlig falsch bewertet haben.
Ich denke, man verbringt halt immer einen langen Teil seiner eigenen Forschung und Lehre auf dem Holzweg so. Aber man muss ihn halt auch gehen, um irgendwo auch anzukommen und Erkenntnisse einzusammeln.
Das ist für mich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Ich glaube das gehört zum Wissenschaft machen dazu, dass man ordentlich Teile seiner Zeit auf dem Holzweg verbringt. Ich bin nun öfter auf Amrum im Urlaub, da ist man viel am Holzweg unterwegs, weil das diese wunderbaren Holzbohlen sind, die so durch die Dünen führen, aber Holzweg gehört zur Wissenschaft dazu. Und ich glaube zum Kreativ sein und zum Dinge ausprobieren gehört eben einfach auch dazu, dass man Ideen als Hypothesen verfolgt und dann eben natürlich dann auch wieder kritisch auf seine eigenen Sachen draufhauen muss. Sagen muss, sind eigentlich die Ergebnisse plausibel, sind eigentlich die Grundannahmen plausibel? Ist die Schlussfolgerung dann eigentlich richtig? Stimmt das eigentlich was ich mache? Und die Hypothese und das Idealbild in der Mathematik ist dann, wenn wir Dinge dann eben einfach fertig haben und überprüft haben und in den Druck geben, dass sie dann auch wirklich stimmen.
Die Wahrheit, mit der ich mich im Moment eben auch abkämpfe, auch mit eigener Forschung und mit der von Kollegen, ist eben einfach, um es positiv zu sagen, das sehr viel interessanter ist als ich vielleicht auch manchmal gedacht hätte, dass es also Mathematikbereiche gibt, wo dann eben auch etliche von den publizierten Dingen einfach nicht stimmen. Und wo dieses eigene und anderer Leute publizierte Dinge aufarbeiten, wieder überprüfen, verstehen, die Fehler darin finden, korrigieren eben auch zum Mathematik machen dazu gehören. Ich meine das alte Idealbild von Mathematik war ja, Euklid hat bewiesen, dass es unendlich viele Primzahlen gibt, das ist ein korrekter Beweis, also gilt es für alle Ewigkeit, mathematische Beweise werden überprüft und dann gelten die für alle Ewigkeit. Das ist das Idealbild. Aber das wird eigentlich sozusagen der Komplexität moderner Forschung nicht gerecht.
Und also ich bin ganz aktuell im Moment am Kämpfen mit meinen Kollegen an einer Arbeit, die wir geschrieben und auch vor einem Jahr veröffentlicht haben, wo sich jetzt rausstellt, die stimmt nicht. Und die stimmt einfach deswegen nicht, weil ein Resultat von einem anderen Mathematiker 1990 veröffentlicht und seitdem etliche Male zitiert und verwendet eben auch nicht stimmt, weil der an einer Stelle, wo man dann, wenn man dann in die Details reinliest, sagt und wie man dann mit einer leichten Rechnung sieht, gilt und so weiter, und genau der Teil ist dann halt nicht richtig, wenn man die leichtere Rechnung nochmal nachmacht. Das heißt mathematische Forschung und mathematisches Schreiben und Mathematik eben auch als dokumentierte Wissenschaft ist sehr viel komplizierter und sehr viel interessanter. Und die Arbeit daran ist sehr viel lebendiger, als man sich vielleicht gedacht hätte.
Qualität von Studien war auch hier jüngst ein Thema, auch wenn wir dort mehr auf den medizinischen Bereich geblickt haben. Wie viel Volatilität ist denn sozusagen in dem erarbeiteten Wissenserbe, auf das die Mathematiker ihre Forschungen basieren? Ich meine vieles hat sich ja irgendwie im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes quasi als solide herausgestellt. Brücken fallen nicht zusammen etc. Also man kann Mathematik ja täglich arbeiten sehen.
Ja gerade bei Brücken fallen nicht zusammen und wenn sie zusammenfallen, dann ist typischerweise nicht die Mathematik dran schuld. Volatilität, also ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt mathematische Forschung und die Ergebnisse mathematischer Forschung mit sozusagen dem Biomedizinbereich vergleichen, wo eben am Ende nur 20-25% der Studien überhaupt reproduzierbar sind, dann ist Mathematik solide wie Beton. Und das ist was wunderbares an Mathematik, dass es dieses ganz klare richtig oder falsch gibt und dass die Dinge im Prinzip nachverfolgbar und nachprüfbar sind und wenn die Argumente stimmen, dann stimmt es und dann stimmt es in alle Ewigkeiten. Aber wie ich ja gerade skizziert habe, wenn man jetzt in einzelne Mathematikbereiche reinschaut, ich glaube dann gibt es da sehr unterschiedliche Standards von Präzision und von Überprüfung vor der Publikation und so weiter.
Das hat sich auch über die letzten 200 Jahre entwickelt in der Mathematik und zwar unterschiedlich früh und unterschiedlich spät und unterschiedlichen Mathematikbereichen. Also in der Analysis zum Beispiel hat Karl Weierstraß hier in Berlin Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts einfach sozusagen die Standards festgeklopft und die Definitionen und die Präzision und die Begriffe, mit denen man arbeiten kann, festgelegt und dokumentiert und da gibt es dieses Schlagwort von der Weierstraßschen Strenge, die funktioniert auch immer noch. Während es zum Beispiel Bereiche in der Topologie gibt, was in dem Bereich der Geometrie ist, wo ich im Moment auch unterwegs bin, wo ich eben einfach auch feststelle, dass da sehr viel eben auch intuitiv dann aufgeschrieben wird und Dinge am Ende eben nicht dokumentiert sind und offenbar Fehler auch mal 20 Jahre in der Fachliteratur überleben können.
Ohne dass es einer merkt. Oder es eben auch Aufsätze gibt, wo zwar alle in der Community wissen, dass das publiziert ist in Annals of Mathematics, was ja angeblich die beste Mathematikzeitschrift der Welt ist, aber trotzdem alle wissen, dass der Beweis nicht vollständig ist oder nie wirklich nachvollzogen worden ist. Und insofern gibt es da die kleinen dunklen Schmutzecken in der Mathematik und das kann man jetzt entweder furchtbar finden oder als Herausforderung finden, um seine Taschenlampe einzupacken und loszuziehen. Oder man kann sagen, in diesen Ecken der Mathematik will ich jetzt nicht arbeiten. Oder man kann sich mittenreinstürzen in sozusagen neueste Mathematikbereiche, wo jetzt wieder ganz frisch die Frage ist, wie müssen wir Beweise aufschreiben, damit die 100% wasserdicht sind.
Und da ist die neueste Entwicklung ja diese sogenannten formalen Beweise, was dann computererzeugte und computerprogrammüberprüfbare Beweise sind, die also sozusagen dann ganz andere Qualitätsstempel noch bekommen können als nur den Stempel, haben sich fünf erfahrene Mathematiker angeschaut und gesagt, das ist richtig. Also da tut sich auch eine Menge sozusagen bei der Theorie der formalen Beweise. Auch wieder entlang von ganz konkreten in dem Fall geometrischen Problemen, wo man sozusagen am Ende eben einen 100% wasserdichten Beweis haben will. Beispiel das Kepler-Problem über die dichteste Packung von gleichgroßen Kugeln im Raum, wo es jetzt so einen Beweis gibt, aber wo es eben auch Leute aus der Topologie gibt. Fields-Medalist Wojewodski zum Beispiel, der sozusagen entnervt aufgegeben hat in seinem Bereich der Topologie.
Weil er gesagt hat, da merke ich, dass meine Sachen da nicht stimmen, weil sie Sachen von anderen Leuten verwenden, die ja auch nicht stimmen und so weiter. Und der stattdessen jetzt in diesen Bereich der formalen Beweise gegangen ist und einer der Exponenten ist, die da versuchen jetzt sozusagen die Beweisverfahren auf der Metaebene für die Mathematik voranzukommen, um Mathematik als Wissenschaft da noch verlässlicher und solider zu machen.
Das touchiert jetzt einen Bereich, den ich ohnehin noch aufbringen wollte. Wir wollten uns ja auch nicht zu sehr in Geschichte verlieren, es ist aber auf jeden Fall klar, das Computerzeitalter ist ja im Prinzip auch eine nachhaltige Änderung der Wissenschaft Mathematik gewesen. Da das mühsame Rechnen anfangs nur von mechanischen Rechenmaschinen teilweise abgelöst worden durch die elektronischen Berechnungsverfahren natürlich auf eine ganz andere Basis gestellt wurden. Auf einmal waren einfach komplexe Berechnungen möglich, die vorher ja einfach nur unter großem Aufwand mit viel Fehlerpotenzial von vielen Menschen, von Rechnern, in der Regel im Übrigen Frauen, gemacht werden konnten. Und letztlich ist ja im Prinzip der Computer ja auch eine Mathematikmaschine sozusagen.
Ich wollte eigentlich so ein bisschen auf die beweisbare Software dann noch hinaus. Das ist jetzt schon erwähnt worden, aber vielleicht nochmal die Frage, was ist das Verhältnis zur Computerei? Mathematiker spielen da ja eine Rolle, aber im Prinzip ist das ja auch nochmal ein ganz anderes Feld geworden, was eine ganz andere Anmutung hat.
Ja ich glaube Computer ist eine Mathematikmaschine ja auch auf ganz unterschiedlichen Ebenen. Und sozusagen auf der untersten Ebene, wo das Konzept eines Computers ja Mathematiker entwickelt haben und die Frage, was Computer auch theoretisch können, ja eine mathematische Frage ist, und eine Frage der mathematischen Logik und da haben dann Kurt Gödel aus Wien, Alan Turing, der ja eben auch gefeiert worden ist. Schwuler Computerpionier aus England. Und John von Neumann, ein ursprünglich ungarischer Mathematiker, der dann in die USA gegangen ist, die alle sozusagen Konzept von Computer, Fragen von Berechenbarkeit, da die ganzen Grundlagen geliefert haben.
So dass wir Computer heutzutage als Mathematikmaschine verstehen können und eben auch sehr tiefliegende Sachen darüber sagen können, was Computer können und was sie prinzipiell nicht können. Und dann die Architektur von Computern ist ja auch was, was aus der Mathematik kommt und was Mathematiker geleistet haben. Unter anderem eben Turing und von Neumann. Wir reden heute auch von der von Neumann-Maschine und von der Turing-Maschine.
Also die Turing-Maschine sozusagen als abstraktes Modell und die von Neumann-Maschine als konkrete Vorschrift, wie eigentlich ein Computer aufgebaut ist, die noch für moderne Computer, die wir heute kaufen, gilt.
Die modernen Computer, die wir heute kaufen, sind glaube ich sowohl weiterhin Turing-Maschinen als auch von Neumann-Maschinen. Von der Turing-Maschine kommen wir vielleicht irgendwann in den nächsten Jahren weg, wenn die es wirklich schaffen, Quantencomputer nicht nur zu entwerfen, sondern eben auch wirklich zu bauen, so dass die verlässlich rechnen. Ich glaube da sind wir noch relativ weit weg, aber das ist dann eine neue Welt, auch von dem was dann theoretisch auf einem Computer möglich ist. Aber die Welt muss man auch erst mal realisieren. Und dieses was theoretisch auf so einem Computer möglich ist, ist dann natürlich auch wieder eine mathematische Frage. Aber auf einer ganz anderen Ebene ist natürlich ein … Oder auf mehreren anderen Ebenen und Metaebenen ist dann Computer eine Mathematikmaschine.
Auf der einen Seite, weil die modernen Computer natürlich mit sehr viel Mathematik entworfen werden und anders gar nicht denkbar sind. Also auch hochintegrierte Schaltkreise sind ohne sehr sehr viel Mathematik nicht zu entwerfen und nicht zu verstehen und nicht zu kontrollieren und so. Und in einer ganz anderen Richtung ist es natürlich so, dass die Computer heutzutage auch die Mathematik verändern. Also das was wir in der Mathematik heutzutage können hat sich natürlich mit der Verfügbarkeit von Hochleistungsrechnern, moderner Numerik, Computeralgebrasystemen, eben auch dem symbolischen Rechnen und so weiter dramatisch verändert. Und Mathematik 2016 würde ganz anders aussehen ohne Computer und könnte das gar nicht sein, was sie heute ist ohne Computer.
Abgesehen davon, dass sie dann auch anders aussehen würde, weil wenn wir heutzutage Mathematik publizieren, dann tun wir das ja auch, indem typischerweise wir Mathematiker unsere Aufsätze und Bücher selbst setzen auf dem Computer in einem Textsatzsystem, das Mathematiker, Informatiker Donald Knuth entworfen hat. Und insofern ist diese Interaktion zwischen Mathematik, Mathematikern und den Computern fängt an mit dem Entwurf des Konzept des Computers und hört auf sozusagen mit dem Textsatz und der Publikation von Mathematik. Was immer noch mit Hilfe von Mathematik von Mathematikern gemacht wird.
Man merkt ja auch, dass die Fortschritte im Bereich der Programmierung, die ja lange Zeit vor allem auch von der Steigerung der Leistungsfähigkeit der Maschinen abhing, man konnte dann mehr tun, man konnte Dinge schneller machen. Dadurch waren bestimmte Anwendungen dann überhaupt erst möglich. Das ein oder andere skalierte damit sozusagen einfach mit der Entwicklung locker mit, kam aber dann immer wieder an einen Punkt, wo grundsätzliche mathematische Errungenschaften einfach auch gefragt waren, um überhaupt Dinge zu ermöglichen. Zum Bespiel die Kryptografie, die ja die Grundlage legt überhaupt für vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation im Netz oder zumindest ansatzweise vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation im Netz, die Dinge in gewisser Hinsicht dann ja auch im Handel miteinander beweisbar macht, Sachen einfach ausschleift der zumindest ihnen eine Wahrscheinlichkeit oder Unwahrscheinlichkeit zuweist, dass man sich da eben drauf vertrauen kann oder eben auch nicht.
Ähnliche Dimensionen denke ich werden jetzt gerade neu eröffnet im Bereich der neuronalen Netzwerke, der künstlichen Intelligenz, der Erforschung dieser Algorithmen, die sozusagen jetzt überhaupt erst in die Lage versetzt wird, mit enorm großen Daten und auch schnell anfallenden Daten arbeiten zu können und dort halt so etwas wie eine Intelligenz zu plakatieren, möglich zu machen. Oder etwas was wir vielleicht so grob als Intelligenz wahrnehmen möchten. Ähnliche Forschungsgebiete gibt es im Bereich Sicherung der Privatsphäre etc. Also Mathematiker sind immer wieder gefordert. Was sind denn so die Felder, die Sie dort sehen, die jetzt die neuen großen Herausforderungen sind, vor denen einerseits die Mathematik steht, aber eben noch die damit verbundenen anderen Wissenschaften und Disziplinen?
Also ich glaube zwei dieser Gebiete haben Sie ja gerade genannt. Ich glaube die gesamten Fragen von Kryptografie, Verschlüsselung, Privatsphäre die werden uns auch weiter umtreiben. Die sind im Moment eben auch besonders interessant, weil auf der einen Seite die Rechnerleistung eben auch zunimmt, um Dinge knacken zu können, die man früher nicht knacken konnte. Auch deswegen weil sozusagen die neuen Quantencomputer, die sozusagen am Horizont stehen, eben sehr viel Kryptografie brechen können oder könnten, wenn es sie dann gibt. Was heutzutage noch als sicher gilt, also wir sind sozusagen jetzt in post Quantumcomputer Kryptografie angekommen, um uns auch eben dagegen zu verteidigen.
Und in Zeiten, wo natürlich auch Geheimhaltung an allen Ecken und Enden ein riesiges Thema ist und die Geheimdienste und weiß Gott wer alles mitspielt, ist dann schon die Frage von, was ist sicher und was ist praktisch sicher und was ist theoretisch sicher, eine ganz große Frage. Und wie kommunizieren wir? Wie kommunizieren wir im Netz? Wie kommunizieren wir schnell? Wie kommunizieren wir vertrauenswürdig und so weiter? Das sind große Mathematikthemen, die werden sicher bleiben und wo es ja auch keine einfachen Antworten gibt und wo das dann nicht irgendwie abgehakt ist. Und das andere Thema künstliche Intelligenz finde ich ein schönes Stichwort. Weil man ja zunächst einmal sagen muss, künstliche Intelligenz ist uns seit den 60er Jahren immer wieder versprochen worden und jede Menge prominente KI-Forscher, die also riesige Versprechungen gemacht haben und am Ende war es immer schwierig genug, eine Maschine dazu zu bringen, ein rotes Dreieck von einem grünen Kreis oder einem blauen Quadrat zu unterscheiden.
Und da ist ja auch eigentlich nichts drauf raus gekommen und man hat sich wahnsinnig lächerlich gemacht letztlich. Und wir haben KI völlig abgeschrieben. Bis dann, und da habe ich eigentlich die großen Ankündigungen dazu nicht gesehen, aber jetzt in den letzten fünf oder zehn Jahren dann plötzliche diese KI-Systeme ja sozusagen einfach routinemäßig auf den Smartphones aufgetaucht sind und die jetzt vielleicht nicht super intelligent sind. Also können wir jetzt mal drüber reden, was für einen IQ Siri eigentlich hat. Aber de facto ist es zunächst mal ein funktionierendes KI-System, was von der Industrie routinemäßig ausgeliefert wird und diese Systeme werden natürlich immer besser werden.
Und ich glaube, da ist KI eben sozusagen dann das Stichwort der Vergangenheit, die haben sich eben einfach auch so sehr blamiert, dass man über künstliche Intelligenz nicht mehr reden wird. Stattdessen reden wir jetzt über Machine Learning, also maschinelles Lernen, was eben letztlich auch eine Hülle ist für eine ganz große Anzahl von unterschiedlichen Methoden und Themenbereichen und Strategien, um intelligent agieren zu können aufgrund von großen Datenmengen. Die gesamte sozusagen intelligente Auswertung von riesigen Datenmengen, Stichwort BigData, gehört da eben auch rein. Und da ist eben in den letzten fünf oder zehn Jahren gigantisches geleistet worden. Da ist aber auch noch sehr viel nötig.
Und das heißt, sehr vieles, was uns da im Moment angeboten wird und vielleicht ein bisschen schon beeindruckt, ist eigentlich noch ziemlich miserabel. Und ich sage mal, wenn man auf Facebook einfach sozusagen die Übersetzen-Taste drückt, dann merkt man, dass das was da an Übersetzung angeliefert wird, sozusagen automatische Übersetzungen, mit einem kleinen bisschen Statistik arbeitet, aber ganz sicher noch nicht als intelligentes System gelten kann. Und das ist einfach noch nicht gut, was da abgeliefert wird. Und das heißt da muss sehr viel mehr Mathematik rein. Da muss sehr viel mehr Technik rein. Und das wird natürlich auch passieren.
Das heißt also ich glaube, automatisches Übersetzen ist eine von den interessanten Techniken, die eben auch von Mathematik profitieren müssen und werden. Datenanalyse ist ein anderes Gebiet. Die Sachen hängen auch alle zusammen. Das sind jetzt sozusagen unterschiedliche Anwendungsfelder, letztlich zum großen Teil für dieselbe Mathematik, wo sich vieles tun muss, wo wir dann auch vorsichtig sein müssen, weil alles was da sozusagen beeindruckende Leistung ist, immer auch eine gefährliche Leistung sein kann. Ich sage mal Datenanalyse interessiert natürlich die Internetgiganten alle, weil die damit sehr viel Geld verdienen können, wenn die unsere eben auch persönlichen Daten effektiv auswerten und da am Ende mehr über uns wissen als wir selber wissen oder wir eigentlich als Informationen hergeben wollen.
Bis hin zu der Frage, wenn sozusagen unser Agieren eben auch international von automatischen Übersetzungen, von Sachen abhängt, was passiert, wenn diese Übersetzungen fehlerhaft sind? Können wir denen vertrauen? Ist das besser, wenn da jetzt ein automatisches Programm plötzlich anfängt zu übersetzen aus russischen Quellen und damit amerikanische Geheimdienste speist oder auch umgekehrt? Ich glaube da tut sich sehr gefährliches eben auch in der Diplomatie, in Privatsphäre und so weiter. Das heißt das Privatsphärethema hängt eben auch an diesen ganzen Sachen dran.
Ja die globale stille Post steht sozusagen vor der Tür und es ist noch nicht so ganz klar …
Stille Post ist ein großes mathematisches Problem.
Ich wollte nochmal auf einen anderen Mathematiker kommen, der sehr großen Einfluss gehabt hat und üblicherweise so in den klassischen Geschichtsaufzeichnungen erst mal nicht so landet, später vielleicht schon. Stephen Wolfram hat die Mathematik ja auch sehr nachhaltig beeinflusst durch ein Softwarepaket Mathematica, was so dem Designer sein Photoshop, das ist dem Mathematiker sein Mathematica. Welche Rolle spielt Mathematica heute noch in der Mathematik? Wie stehen Sie auch dazu, auch zu Stephen Wolfram und vielleicht auch noch ein paar Sätze zu seiner Vision mit Wolfram Alpha, die Welt mathematisch verständlich zu machen?
Das ist eine komplexe Frage, auch weil Stephen Wolfram glaube ich auch eine komplexe Figur ist und ich glaube ich würde dann sozusagen diese unterschiedlichen Handlungsfelder getrennt anschauen. Also zunächst mal, Mathematica ist ja ein Computeralgebrasystem, eines der großen und erfolgreichen, aber nicht das einzige. Das hatte auch seine Vorläufer und seine Tradition, also Maxima war zum Beispiel eines, was heutzutage glaube ich gar nicht mehr läuft. Im Moment glaube ich, also sozusagen vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich noch gesagt, die beiden großen Softwarepakete, die wir Mathematiker eben auch verwenden, ist eben auf der einen Seite Mathematica, also das Wolfram-Ding und andererseits Maple, was ein Produkt von einem kanadischen Universitätskonsortium ist.
Und ich habe immer Maple gegenüber Mathematica präferiert. Jetzt würde ich sagen, man muss eigentlich aufpassen auf das was Sage macht, ein neues Paket, was anders funktioniert. Nämlich auch kostenlos zu haben ist und letztlich ein Community Afford ist, also von vielen gemeinsam und von der ganzen Community von Entwicklern gemeinsam entwickelt und öffentlich zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Und da kann es sein, dass das am Ende dann eben auch Mathematica und Maple auf das Abstellgleis bringt. Muss man sehen. In der Tat ist es so, dass diese Computeralgebraprogramme, eben auch Mathematica, gigantisch viel können. Da ist also einfach sehr viel auch klassische Mathematik algorithmisch implementiert worden, so dass es jetzt zur Verfügung steht. Was sehr nützlich ist eben auch fürs Rechnen.
Wo man, wenn man dann mathematische Forschung macht, sich dann immer ärgert, dass Mathematica zwar Ergebnisse ausspuckt, aber nicht die Begründungen dafür, also dass es sehr schwer ist, aus solchen Paketen dann nicht nur das Ergebnis der Rechnung, sondern auch den Rechenweg rauszukitzeln und das ist eigentlich das was wir brauchen. Wir müssen am Ende doch nicht nur wissen, dass diese Regal – Regal sag ich schon – dieses Integral am Ende Ergebnis 42 liefert, sondern wir müssen auch wissen, nach welchem Rechenweg ausgewertet das am Ende 42 liefert und ob die Antwort eben wirklich 42 ist oder 42,0012. Das sind dann eben einfach Dinge, die man eben rausholen muss, insofern muss man immer aufpassen.
Man muss halt nicht nur wissen wie die Frage ist, sondern man muss auch wissen, wie die Frage formuliert war, um mit der Antwort was anfangen zu können.
Und für die Antwort braucht man eine Begründung und diese Computeralgebrasysteme sind immer tendenziell sehr gut in Antworten und nicht so gesprächig, was die Begründungen angeht. Aber sie sind ein großer Gewinn für die Mathematik und es gibt sicher Bereiche der mathematischen Forschung, die heutzutage gar nicht so agieren können, wie sie es tun, wenn wir nicht Computeralgebrasysteme hätten und da gilt letztlich mein Bereich, wenn ich Polyedertheorie mache, ganz genauso. Diese anderen Visionen von Wolfram, eben Wolfram Alpha, sozusagen dieser Versuch, die gesamte Welt sozusagen in Automaten, also was er dann Automaten nennt, zu erklären, da bin ich eigentlich sehr skeptisch, was vielleicht ein bisschen daran liegt, dass ich alle Welterklärer erst mal sehr skeptisch hinschaue und zuhöre.
Also manches von dem, was Wolfram da abliefert, ist sicher sehr nützlich und kann gut verwendet werden, aber zur Welterklärung am Ende glaube ich taugt es nicht. Also taugt es mir zumindest nicht.
Aber es macht Mathematik auf eine interessante Art und Weise erschließbar. Also dieses Beispiel vom Pythagoras im Supermarkt, man hat es dann halt doch nicht ganz immer so parat und braucht es auch selten genug, als dass es sich jetzt wirklich lohnen würde, das die ganze Zeit so in seinem Tagesgedächtnis wieder abzurufen. Aber so die Möglichkeit, mal eben Dinge in Relation zum Erdäquator zu setzen und das weiß ich noch durch was für andere wirre Parameter zu teilen, finde ich eine schöne auch spaßige Auseinandersetzung mit Mathematik an der Stelle, die dann eben auch wieder, wo wir eingangs ja auch waren, so diese Frage auch immer wieder schön beantwortet, wozu muss ich mich denn eigentlich mit Mathematik beschäftigen?
Ja es liefert einem eine völlig neue Art sozusagen Mathematik zu erfahren und zuzugreifen und insofern ist es sicher interessant und spannend und sehr hilfreich. Das ist dann nicht die Art von Zugriff auf Mathematik, die ich brauche, wenn ich mathematische Forschung mache, aber das ist natürlich auch nur eine der Perspektiven auf Mathematik.
Kommen wir vielleicht doch nochmal kurz zu Ihrem Forschungsbereich, der umfasst unter anderem etwas was unter dem Begriff diskrete Mathematik oder diskrete Geometrie geführt wird. Können Sie das mal kurz näherbringend, was eigentlich so Ihr aktueller Weg, aktueller Holzweg sozusagen ist, den Sie beschreiben.
Hoffentlich nicht nur Holzwege. Zunächst einmal das kanonische Wortspiel ist natürlich, diskrete Mathematik von indiskreter Mathematik abzugrenzen. Diskret ist glaube ich von lateinisch discernere unterscheiden, also diskret sind alle Strukturen, die sozusagen aus endlich vielen Einzelteilen bestehen. Das Gegenteil von diskret ist kontinuierlich letztlich. Also kontinuierliche Mathematik da gehört die gesamte Analysis dazu. Zur diskreten Mathematik gehört die Grafentheorie dazu. Ein Fahrplan zum Beispiel ist ein ganz klares Beispiel von diskreter Mathematik. Die Straßenbahn hat eben so und so viele Haltestellen und hat Verbindungen zwischen den Haltestellen und so weiter und das ist alles was man mit endlichen Listen und Strukturen beschreiben kann ist diskrete Mathematik.
Wenn ich diskrete Geometrie mache, dann geht es eben wieder nicht primär um die geschwungenen Strukturen und was ich mit Differentialgleichungen und Analysis beschreiben kann, sondern dann geht es um das, was ich sozusagen an Modellen zusammensetzen kann aus endlich vielen Ecken und Kanten und Dreiecken und Vierecken. Und was mich fasziniert ist dann die Theorie der Polyeder, wo die klassischen griechischen Polyeder eben die regulären sind, wo alle Seitenflächen gleich sein müssen und an jeder Ecke gleich viele und so weiter. Mich interessieren allgemeine Polyeder, die eben sehr unterschiedliche Seitenflächen haben können. Und mich interessieren insbesondere die vierdimensionalen Polyeder, die sind irgendwie noch sehr viel spannender, als was sich im dreidimensionalen Raum tut, die sind auch sehr viel weniger gut verstanden.
Was natürlich auch daran liegt, dass man sie sich nicht so leicht vorstellen kann. Aber die Oberfläche von einem vierdimensionalen Polyeder ist am Ende eben doch eine dreidimensionale Struktur und das was wir eigentlich verstehen müssen und sehr viel besser verstehen müssen ist dreidimensionale Kristallstrukturen oder Dinge, die aussehen wie Kristalle. Also alles was passiert, wenn ich sozusagen Polyeder in einen Raum packe. Ich meine, wenn ich kleine Würfelchen packe, dann weiß ich wie das aussieht, das sieht man in jeder Zuckerwürfelschachtel, wie man sozusagen Würfel packen kann oder die Paketstapel bei der DHL, bevor die dann irgendwann ausgeliefert werden, das sind sozusagen Packungen von Polyedern, wobei ich die Polyeder jetzt nicht besonders interessant finde, aber wenn wir Polyeder mit sehr viel mehr Seitenflächen haben, unregelmäßig, und versuchen, die eben doch im Raum zu packen und versuchen zu verstehen, wie das zusammenpasst, können wir den Raum zum Beispiel lückenlos füllen mit Polyedern, die alle sehr viele Seitenflächen haben und nicht nur sechs wie ein Würfel.
Da sind wir plötzlich in ungelösten Fragestellungen drin und das sind alles Fragen der diskreten Geometrie. Diskret weil wir es mit diskret geometrischen Objekten, also zum Beispiel Polyedern mit endlich vielen Ecken und Kanten zu tun haben und Geometrie, weil wir eigentlich in der Raumgeometrie unterwegs sind.
Was ist denn die vierte Dimension?
Die vierte Dimension ist zunächst mal was, was ich als mathematisches Modell relativ leicht hinschreiben kann. Wo wir eben gewohnt sind, die Punkte in der Ebene als Vektoren mit zwei Koordinaten zu beschreiben und den Raum zu beschreiben mit Vektoren, die eben drei Koordinaten haben, wobei das immer Länger, Breite, Höhe sozusagen die drei Koordinaten sind. Und genauso wie man eben mit Vektoren der Länge zwei wie in der Ebene rechnen kann und mit Vektoren der Länge drei rechnen kann, kann man auch mit Vektoren der Länge vier rechnen, die dann eben vier Einträge haben. Und um mit denen zu rechnen, muss ich sie nicht interpretieren, also insofern ist die vierte Koordinate dann X4.
Ja gut, aber einfach nur rechnen, ohne sich da irgendwas darunter vorstellen zu können, das ist doch eigentlich genau der Moment, wo die Leute die Party verlassen?
Das ist der Triumph der Algebra, dass man eben Dinge rechnen kann, ohne sie interpretieren zu müssen. Ist am Ende nicht mein Ding. Ich will mir schon Dinge vorstellen und das ist dann, weil ich eben einfach Geometer bin und nicht Algebraiker. Es stellt sich raus, dass aber dieses Wechselspiel zwischen, ich habe ein abstraktes algebraisches Modell, in dem ich rechnen kann und geometrische Dinge, die ich mir vorstellen kann, ausgesprochen produktiv ist. Ich kann algebraische Strukturen konstruieren, weil ich geometrische Intuitionen dafür habe oder geometrische Strukturen verstehen, weil ich algebraisch damit rechnen kann. Und es gibt dann eben ganz unterschiedliche Arten, diese Dinge eben auch zu interpretieren. Und der große Klassiker ist natürlich, dass ich sage, ich kann die vierte Dimension auch mal als Zeit interpretieren.
Und die gesamte Relativitätstheorie von Einstein, und Minkowski ist dann der Mathematiker dahinter, die beruht natürlich genau darauf, dass wir dieses tun. Aber das ist eben sozusagen nur eine mögliche Interpretation. Vektoren mit mehr als drei Einträgen tauchen sowohl in geometrischen als auch in anderen Kontexten auf und ist nützlich, die zu verstehen.
Für wen ist das denn nützlich, das zu verstehen, außer für die Mathematik selbst? Also vielleicht auch für die Mathematik selbst. Also wofür liefert das sozusagen, wie muss man sich das vorstellen, wofür das wiederum eine Basis liefern könnte, wenn dort ein Verständnis von Dingen erarbeitet wurde und wo greift es unter Umständen über die Mathematik hinaus?
Also ich glaube zunächst mal ist es in der Mathematik absolut fundamental. Also so wie wir zum Beispiel in Deutschland ein Mathematikstudium machen, gehört sozusagen ins erste Semester die Vorlesung in Analysis und die Vorlesung in linearer Algebra und in linearer Algebra lernt man eben, dass sozusagen die Algebra, die man braucht, um mit beliebig langen Vektoren und eben in Räumen beliebiger Dimensionen zu rechnen. Und das ist dann fundamental für alles andere, am Ende natürlich auch für den Wetterbericht. Weil wenn Wetterbericht natürlich darauf beruht, dass ich an 6.000 Wetterstationen in Deutschland jeweils einen Datenpunkt habe, nämlich was weiß ich eine Temperatur und daraus versuche, jetzt auszurechnen die Temperatur in einer Stunde, dann ist diese Liste der 6.000 Temperaturen jetzt ist eben ein Vektor der Länge 6.000.
Und die Temperatur in Deutschland in einer Stunde ist eben wieder ein Vektor der Dimension 6.000 und das heißt, wenn wir mit großen Datenmengen rechnen, dann rechnen wir immer mit langen Vektoren und eine Methode, das zu interpretieren, ist zu sagen, wir rechnen in einem hochdimensionalen Raum. Wir können die Dinge jetzt unterschiedlich sortieren. Wir können natürlich jetzt auch die Datenpunkte in Deutschland wieder sozusagen in der Fläche anordnen, aber dann haben wir eben doch wieder für jeden Punkt eine ganze Menge Daten. Nämlich sozusagen Länge und Breite und Höhe vielleicht und Temperatur und noch eine Windrichtung und so weiter Also wir haben es immer mit komplexen Daten zu tun, und das heißt eigentlich mit hochdimensionaler Geometrie, ob wir wollen oder nicht.
Also in der Mathematik ist es wichtig, für die Interpretation von Mathematik ist es wichtig. Ich glaube, wenn wir sozusagen zurückgehen zu einem früheren Punkt, den wir diskutiert haben, ich glaube die Fähigkeit der Menschheit eben auch hochdimensionale Geometrie zu verstehen ist wieder ein Teil der Kultur. Und ich habe gesagt, Euklid ist der Glanzpunkt, dass der die dreidimensionalen regulären Polyeder klassifizieren konnte und sagen konnte, da gibt es nur fünf Stück davon. Sozusagen ein Meilenstein der Menschheit ist dann der Schweizer Geometer Ludwig Schläfli, der um 1850 rum die vierdimensionalen regulären Polyeder verstanden hat und zeigen konnte, da gibt es eben nicht nur fünf davon, sondern sogar sechs und die sind spannend. Die kann man inzwischen auch visualisieren. Das gibt ganz tolle Bilder.
Und die Klassifikation der regelmäßigen Strukturen und da gehören eben die regulären Polyeder dazu, ist dann Kulturleistung. Genauso wie dieses, wir können hochdimensionale Geometrie verstehen und wir können sie anwenden, das muss man zumindest wissen. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass wir das sozusagen in der 9. Klasse lernen müssen, wie man das macht und es braucht eben auch keiner an der Supermarktkasse. Das heißt sozusagen hochdimensionale Vektorrechnung gehört jetzt sozusagen zum Kulturwissen, dass das geht. Gehört nicht zu dem Werkzeugkasten, von dem was wir täglich an der Supermarktkasse brauchen. Aber es gehört dann eben doch wieder zu dem Handwerkszeug jedes Ingenieurs und jedes Naturwissenschaftlers und natürlich jedes Menschen, der anfangen will, Mathematik zu studieren und der versucht, die Welt zu verstehen.
Und wir wissen inzwischen eben, dass man die Welt nicht verstehen kann, zumindest in einem naturwissenschaftlichen Sinne, wenn man nicht bereit ist, sich auf hochdimensionale Geometrie einzulassen.
Womit wir aber auch beim Wetterbericht der anderen Art sind. Viel in der Diskussion, auch hier zuletzt bei Forschergeist sind natürlich die Ausblicke auf den Klimawandel auf diesem Planeten. Und gerade die führende Gruppe in diesem Bereich, IPCC, die UN-Mission, die sozusagen die Klimafolgenabschätzungen nun tatsächlich vornimmt, basiert ja vor allem auf solchen Wetterberichten. Die halt versuchen, möglichst lange in die Zukunft zu blicken, was nicht einfach ist, wie man schon sieht an dem Wetterbericht für übermorgen, der mal so mal so ausfallen kann. Auch wenn da schon ganz interessante Genauigkeit erreicht werden. Welchen Einfluss hat dann Ihre Arbeit, so eine Arbeit, Mathematik im Allgemeinen konkret auf diese Klimamodelle?
Also was ich in meiner persönlichen Forschung mache ist sozusagen abstrakte Geometrie. Das ist jetzt nichts, was jetzt sozusagen direkt uns mit dem Wetter oder dem Klima helfen wird. Aber ich glaube, es ist einfach wichtig, abstrakte Geometrie voranzutreiben, auch deswegen weil die Geometrie ihren Beitrag zu diesen ganzen Dingen liefert. Wenn man jetzt gerade über Klimamodelle redet, man muss natürlich zunächst einmal Wetter und Klima auseinanderhalten. Das sind auch zwei sehr unterschiedliche Dinge. Ich glaube, dass aber in der Tat auch in der aufgeheizten internationalen Diskussion über Weltklimaberichte und über diese ganzen Dinge es eigentlich wichtig ist, zumindest skizzenweise und ansatzweise, zu verstehen, was diese Klimamodelle eigentlich sind, wie die aufgesetzt werden, was die können, was die nicht können, was da das Potenzial ist und in wie weit man denen trauen kann.
Da hängen eben auch Fragen dran wie, haben wir denn eigentlich genug Daten oder welche Arten von Daten brauchen wir denn eigentlich, um da irgendwie verlässliche Modelle zu rechnen? Wie sehen wir denn eigentlich einem Modell an, ob es verlässlich ist? Und da gibt es ja sehr interessante Ansätze sozusagen Klimamodelle mal mit relativ wenig Datenpunkten zu rechen, dass man sagt, also den atlantischen Ozean modellieren wir jetzt mal mit 200 Datenpunkten, die natürlich nicht den gesamten Ozean überspannen, aber setzen da jetzt intelligente, sehr reduzierte Modelle drauf und kalibrieren die so, dass die eben auch schon mal die Vergangenheit richtig modellieren können. Und was die Klimamodellierer machen ist dann ja, Klimamodelle aufsetzen, die eben vor 20.000 Jahren anfangen oder sehr viel früher noch.
Und die dann erst mal sozusagen korrekt reproduzieren, wie es sozusagen mit einer Abfolge von Erwärmungen, Abkühlungen und Eiszeiten und so weiter aussieht.
Also die fangen sozusagen beim Ishango-Knochen an?
Richtig. Und die dann eben einfach, wenn die ein realistisches Modell von Klima für die Vergangenheit bringen können, dann kann man denen vielleicht auch ein Stück weit trauen, dass das was die in der Fortsetzung dann bringen können stimmen könnte, wobei man dann eben überlegen muss auch, wie sich die Daten verändern und was die Einflussmöglichkeiten jetzt eben von dem ist, was wir als Mensch im Moment eben am Klima verändern. Das ist ja der große Streitpunkt. Aber sozusagen diese großen Klimastudien einfach immer herzunehmen mit der Frage, das haben jetzt Wissenschaftler gerechnet und das Gesicht von Herrn, was weiß ich, Schellenhuber sieht vertrauenswürdig aus, sollte natürlich als Grundlage von gesellschaftlichen Entscheidungen und von großer Politik am Ende nicht ausreichen.
Sondern ein Grundverständnis dafür, was eigentlich in solchen Modellen gerechnet wird. Wie sicher oder unsicher solche Modelle sein können. Was ist denn eigentlich ein Rechenmodell für ein Klima? Ich glaube das sind große Fragen und denen muss man sich dann in Ruhe stellen. Und ich kann an dieser Stelle nur sagen, das ist alles hochdimensionale Vektorrechnung.
Das ist ja eine Frage der Kommunikation auch mit der Öffentlichkeit, die dann sozusagen über die eigenen wissenschaftlichen Sphären deutlich hinausgehen. Sicherlich angemessen an der Stelle nochmal drauf hinzuweisen, Sie haben ja auch den von DFG und Stifterverband ausgelobten Kommunikator-Preis erhalten, schon vor einiger Zeit, vor acht Jahren 2008, wo ja im Prinzip Ihre Arbeit auch gerade in dieser Hinsicht gewürdigt wurde. Also die öffentliche Vermittlung der Mathematik, die wir ja hier auch gerade betreiben. Was sollte der Beitrag sein der Wissenschaft und der Mathematik im Besonderen, um diese Vertrauensrelation der Öffentlichkeit auch herzustellen? Was ist geschehen, was sollte noch geschehen, was ist wichtig? Auch für den Einzelnen, der jetzt in die Wissenschaft und speziell in die Mathematik geht, um dieses Verhältnis zur Öffentlichkeit gerecht zu gestalten?
Also wir reden ja jetzt immer über die Mathematik. Und ich habe sozusagen zwei große Dinge eben auch in den letzten Jahren gelernt und versucht mich daran zu orientieren und die umzusetzen. Und das eine ist die Erkenntnis, dass es die Mathematik in dem Sinne nicht gibt. Sondern wenn wir über Mathematik reden, dann reden wir über sehr vielfältige Dinge und sehr viele Sachen, die da dazugehören und sehr viele verschiedene Aspekte. Ich hatte das mit diesen drei Schulfächern aufgefächert, aber Mathematik als Wissenschaft ist schon so gigantisch groß mit 5.020 Einzeldisziplinen, die man sozusagen aufzählen kann. Aber Mathematik ist ja auch nicht nur Wissenschaft, Mathematik ist eben auch Schulfach, Mathematik ist was, was wir im Alltag machen.
Mathematik sind die Sudoku-Rätsel in der Tageszeitung. Mathematik ist der Wetterbericht, insbesondere wenn er stimmt. Und insofern ist Mathematik eben einfach was sehr vielfältiges und ich glaube, wir müssen Mathematik als sehr vielfältig darstellen. Und ich glaube, es gibt sehr wenige korrekte Sätze über die Mathematik. Genauso wie es eigentlich sehr wenig korrekte Sätze über die Deutschen gibt. Also ein Satz über die Deutschen ist typischerweise falsch.
Kann man eigentlich auch gleich beenden.
Sätze über die Juden erst recht.
Genauso.
Ja genau. Aber die Mathematik ist auch so was vielfältiges, vielleicht genauso vielfältig wie die Deutschen, dass man glaube ich da einfach in die Aspekte reingehen muss. Und ich habe auch in dem was ich die letzten Jahre gemacht habe versucht, Mathematik auszubreiten. Also ich habe zwei Bücher gemacht in den letzten Jahren. Das eine war, was ich mein Geschichtenbuch nenne, heißt „Darf ich Zahlen – Geschichten aus der Mathematik“ und versucht genau sozusagen die Vielfalt der Mathematik in Erzählungen auszubreiten. Und das zweite Buch hieß dann „Mathematik das ist doch keine Kunst“ und ist mein Bilderbuch. Wo ich mir 24 Bilder vorgenommen habe und versucht habe zu jedem der Bilder die Geschichte zu erzählen oder zumindest einen Teil der Geschichte. Und das erste Bild ist ein Foto von diesem Ishango-Knochen. Mit den Primzahlen drauf, 22.000 Jahre alt.
Und mein Lieblingsbild und die Lieblingsgeschichte ist die von dem Mädchen mit den Taschenrechnern. Ist so ein Pressefoto, was immer wieder auftaucht, wenn diese Studie kommt, die sagt, Mädels können eben doch Mathe und mindestens genauso gut wie die Jungs. Also so ein typisches Thema, sauer Gurken Zeit. Und da ist mir irgendwann aufgefallen, dass da immer wieder dasselbe Pressefoto auftaucht von einem kleinen Mädchen, das vor Taschenrechnern sitzt. Und ich habe dann meinen Ehrgeiz entwickelt. Habe gesagt, wenn jetzt dieses Mädel da schon als Postergirl herhalten muss für Mädels können Mathe, dann möchte ich eigentlich wissen, was das Mädel dazu sagt. Und durch einen ziemlichen Zufall habe ich dann festgestellt, dass der Pressetext zu dem Bild noch in der Bilddatei drinsteckt, die im Internet rumschwirrt und das Mädchen heißt Sarah Sherry und kommt offenbar aus Manchester. Und habe dann versucht, den Direktor ihrer Schule zu kontaktieren.
Der hat sich nicht gemeldet, also habe ich mal ein Dutzend Frauen auf Facebook angeschrieben, die ich nicht kenne, das mache ich üblicherweise nicht und habe gesagt, es gibt da dieses Pressefoto von Sarah Sherry, sind Sie die Sarah Sherry? Und in der Tat hat eine von denen geantwortet und hat gesagt, ja ich bin das Mädel auf dem Poster, auf dem Foto. Und diese Sarah Sherry ist inzwischen über 20 und studiert in Manchester Material Science and Ingeneering, also Ingenieurwissenschaften und sehr geeignetes Postergirl für Mädels können Mathe. Das ist so eine Geschichte hinter einem Bild, was Mathe in der Öffentlichkeit eben einfach repräsentiert. Und dass sozusagen dieses Geschichten zu Bildern. Und das war dieses Buch, aber das ist eigentlich auch dieser zweite Aspekt, wo es dann immer heißt, Mathe erklären.
Und ich irgendwann festgestellt habe, nur weil ich einen Kommunikator-Preis habe, kann ich jetzt auch nicht der Öffentlichkeit Mathematik so erklären, dass wenn Günther Ziegler erklärt, dann haben es alle verstanden. Das ist diese absurde Vorstellung von dem Nürnberger Trichter, die auch in manchen von diesen sozusagen Internet-Lehrprojekten drinsteckt. Berühmter Stanford-Professor oder wegen mir berühmter Berlin-Professor erklärt und dann haben es alle verstanden, das funktioniert einfach nicht. Mathematik ist schwierig und dazu muss man auch stehen. Und das was ich eben auch in der Öffentlichkeit machen kann ist jetzt nicht Mathe besser erklären als alle anderen, sondern von Mathematik erzählen. Ich glaube ich habe die Aufgabe zu erzählen. Und ich habe die Aufgabe und stelle mich der Aufgabe, aus der Mathematik zu erzählen, Bereiche die ich mache, die ich wahrgenommen habe. Wo es diese wunderbaren Geschichten gibt.
Wo ich einfach in das Fach reinführen kann mit den Geschichten des Faches und mit den Bildern zum Fach und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass es ein ganz tolles Fach ist und eines was mich fasziniert und was viele andere fasziniert und faszinieren kann. Wobei diese ganze Vielfalt eben einfach auch heißt, dass es da sehr viele Zugänge gibt in die Mathematik rein. Ich bin eben damals durch die Mathewettbewerbe reingekommen, weil ich eben einfach ein ehrgeiziger Junge war und es allen zeigen wollte. Andere Leute gehen in die Mathematik rein, weil Mathematik rein, weil Mathematik einfach große Kunst ist und weil das in der Tat eine künstlerische Tätigkeit ist, Mathematik zu machen. Und weil diese Strukturen, mit denen man da spielen kann oder arbeiten kann, eben einfach auch ungeheuer schön sind und sozusagen diese Begeisterung für diese Strukturen eben einfach einen in die Mathematik reinführt.
Und dann gibt es noch ein Dutzend andere Zugänge zur Mathematik. Also einer zum Beispiel ist der, dass man sagt, Mathe hat ganz wunderbar Jobs. Und sozusagen mit dem Mathematikstudium kann man was werden und kann man in der Welt was bewegen. Das war nun überhaupt nicht mein Zugang, als ich angefangen habe, Mathe zu studieren. Da habe ich nicht drüber nachgedacht, was man mit Mathe eigentlich machen kann. Aber heutzutage, also wenn die Beratung für die Schüler und Schülerinnen ist, studier Mathe, damit hast du alle Möglichkeiten der Welt, das stimmte damals auch nicht, als ich studieren angefangen habe und heute stimmt es eben und ich glaube das ist auch eine gute Motivation fürs Mathematikstudium.
Wo Sie es jetzt gerade angesprochen haben, das Mädchen mit dem Taschenrechner, das Bild auch der Frauen in der Mathematik das ist ja eine ähnliche Leidensgeschichte auch im Computersektor. Ich hatte ja eingangs schon erwähnt, anfangs waren alle Rechner eigentlich Rechnerinnen, weil Frauen halt einfach massenhaft im Rechnen beschäftigt waren, besonders dann nochmal in der Kriegsphase. Später haben dann die Herren herausgefunden, dass das ja eigentlich ganz cool ist mit dem Programmieren, was ja dann die Mädchen und die Frauen auch übernommen haben. Und seitdem hat sich das so ein bisschen umgedreht. Und heute gelten natürlich auch viele Wissenschaften und insbesondere eben die technischeren und auch sicherlich die Mathematik als so ein bisschen undurchlässig für Frauen. Stelle ich das falsch dar, hat sich das vielleicht geändert? Was müsste sich da noch tun?
Also wenn Sie behaupten, sie gelten als undurchlässig und so weiter, dann stellen Sie das natürlich nicht falsch dar, sondern dann ist das eben ein Teil der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung. Also es ist so, dass Mathematik, wenn man an die Hochschulen schaut, wie sieht ein Mathematikstudium aus, wir haben so zwischen 40-50% Frauen unter den Anfängern im Mathematikstudium. Also insofern ein Mädel, das zu uns kommt, um Mathematik zu studieren, ist erstens mal herzlich willkommen und ist da dann auch nicht die einzige in der Vorlesung, sondern das ist ein Studium für Männer und Frauen, die dann alle sozusagen gemeinsam reingehen in das Ganze. Da hat sich auch massiv was verändert. Das war vor 30 Jahren sicher noch ganz anders. Und da sind auch nicht alle Fächer angekommen.
Also in gewissen Bereichen des Maschinenbaus oder Ingenieurstudiengängen, da ist man im Prinzip durchaus noch alleine auf weiter Flur, wenn man da anfängt. Das ist in der Mathematik nicht so. Wenn man sich die Statistik anschaut in der Mathematik, also zunächst einmal die Frage, ob Frauen genauso Mathe können wie Männer, die hat sich nun wirklich erledigt, das ist einfach klar. Und da wird auch nicht mehr groß diskutiert. Trotzdem ist es so, dass wenn man sich dann anschaut, wie viel Prozent haben wir Doktorandinnen und wie viel Prozent haben wir Habilitandinnen, wie viele Prozent Mathematikprofessorinnen haben wir in der Republik, dann nimmt der Prozentsatz Frauen immer ab nach oben. Und ich glaube, wir haben am Ende 12% Mathematikprofessorinnen. Das ist also ein Achtel immerhin, aber natürlich nicht die Hälfte von denen, die angefangen haben.
Und warum jetzt eben nur ein Teil der Frauen wirklich sozusagen den ganzen Weg rauf akademische Karriere bis zur Professur geht hat natürlich viele Gründe. Ich sage mal drei davon. Also einer ist, Mathematik ist ein schwieriges Fach und es ist eines, wo man Durchhaltevermögen braucht und das muss man dann auch wirklich wollen. Und zwar über Jahre. Und wissenschaftliche Karriere ist dann eben einfach anstrengend und da kann natürlich dann so eine Entscheidung auch sein, auf die Dauer will ich dann so eine Karriere nicht, sondern ich will stattdessen Familie und Kinder und so weiter. Wir versuchen, Universität eben auch so zu gestalten, dass das jetzt keine Alternative ist, die sich ausschließt. Und wir haben ich fantastische Mathematikerinnen auf dem Weg nach oben mit Kindern und Familie und so weiter. Schließt sich nicht aus. Aber wird eben teilweise so gesehen.
Ein zweiter Teil ist der, dass es ich glaube für jede solche Karriere eben einfach auch Vorbilder braucht. Und wenn man sozusagen das alte Stereotyp nimmt, ein Mathematiker ist also ein Mann mit dicker Brille und langem Bart, der sich für sein Fach begeistert, aber ansonsten wenige Interessen hat, …
Sozial leicht verstört am besten noch.
Sozial leicht verstört. Also ich meine es gibt da eine britische Studie von vor ein paar Jahren, wo man eben Jugendliche gefragt hat, was sie sich eben unter einem Mathematiker vorstellen und da kam das da raus. Also das ist eben das Stereotyp. Und ich sage mal, wenn ein 18-jähriges Mädchen dann sagt, wenn ich mal groß bin, will ich so einer werden, dann ist die Antwort natürlich, nein. Das heißt der Wille, ich will Mathematikerin werden, ich will Mathematikprofessorin werden, für den ist es natürlich hilfreich, wenn man dafür eben einfach auch ein Bild von und ein entspanntes und ein fröhliches und ein interessantes und ein vielfältiges Bild davon im Kopf hat, dass es Mathematikprofessorinnen gibt und was die machen und dass die Spaß an ihrem Fach haben und dass die genauso da in der fröhlichen Wissenschaft unterwegs sind, wie ihre männlichen Kollegen.
Und mit denen gemeinsam und dass wir da eben einfach gemeinsam eine Menge leisten und leisten können. Ich glaube dieses Bild muss man aufbauen und insofern kommt es eben auch sehr langsam, dass wir, wenn wir jetzt sozusagen diesen Punkt erreicht haben, wo wir eben gleiche Menge von Männern und Frauen als Studienanfänger haben in der Mathematik, dann heißt es noch lange nicht, dass wir gleiche Anzahl Männer und Frauen als Vorbilder anzubieten haben, die jetzt sozusagen in den oberen Rängen der Wissenschaft unterwegs sind. Und insofern ist es eine Entwicklung und auch eine, die Zeit braucht. Aber ich glaube eine, die kommt. Und der dritte Aspekt, ich hatte ja drei Aspekte angeboten und Mathematiker können ja bekanntlich nicht zählen, ist dann schon dass ich glaube, dass Männer und Frauen unterschiedlich sind.
Und einer der Aspekte, wo man das sieht, ist eben die Frage von, mit wie viel Selbstvertrauen gehe ich rein in eine Sache. Und Mathe ist ein schweres Fach, das wird teilweise anders kommuniziert, wo man dann eben sagt, streng dich nur an, dann kannst du das. Und wenn man es richtig erklärt, dann ist das alles ganz einfach. Das ist allemal für Hochschulmathematik nicht wahr. Mathematik ist schwierig und Mathematik als Wissenschaft ist schwierig. Das macht es für mich auch interessant und für andere. Aber das heißt eben einfach auch, das ist was wo man sich durchbeißen muss. Und das mit dem Durchbeißen läuft natürlich am einfachsten, wenn ich mir einfach sage, ich kann das, ich traue mir das zu, und ich laufe da mit Selbstvertrauen rein und so eine Mischung aus Selbstvertrauen und Fröhlichkeit und ich kann das, bringt einen ziemlich weit.
Und aus meiner Erfahrung sind darin Männer besser als Frauen. Statistisch gesehen zumindest.
Bzw. sie haben mehr den Trend, blind auf etwas zuzurennen, ohne sich über die Konsequenzen Gedanken zu machen, um es mal etwas anders zu sagen.
Die nächste Frage ist natürlich, ist das gut? Ich erinnere mich an meinen ersten Diplomanden TU Berlin vor so ungefähr 15 Jahren, der also seine Diplomarbeit abgegeben hatte, wo ich dann sehr lange noch mit dem Zweitkorrektor telefoniert habe über die Frage, ob wir da noch eine 4 geben können. Es war wirklich eine miserable Arbeit. Und gleich auf der dritten Seite standen dann also Dinge, die nun völlig falsch waren, mit einem selbstbewussten Zitat ins Lehrbuch rein. Aber das war eben dieses Modell Basketballtrainer strotzte vor Selbstbewusstsein und hat nach der Diplomarbeit einen Traineejob bei der Allianz in München angenommen und dann Karriere gemacht. Sozusagen diese Modell, ich kann das. Und so was kenne ich von Frauen eigentlich sehr viel weniger. Und unsere Gesellschaft ist dann immer noch eigentlich sehr gut damit, Leute zu entmutigen.
Also vor ein paar Jahren hatte Otto-Versand dieses T-Shirt sehr populär im Katalog, Mädchen T-Shirt, also auch in Babygrößen zu haben, wo draufsteht „In Mathe bin ich Deko“.
Furchtbar.
Furchtbar. Und ich sage mal, wenn man da mal die Blogeinträge da auf der Otto-Homepage gesehen hat, da gab es da Mütter, die sagten, tolle Farbe, witziger Spruch und so weiter. Also welche Mutter schickt da ihre Tochter in die Kita mit einem T-Shirt, auf dem draufsteht, ich bin doof? Oder eben auch, ich traue mir das nicht zu. Und ich glaube, da wird eben auch von – und jetzt sind wir in traditionellen Rollenbildern drin – da wird von Müttern auf Töchter weitergegeben dieses, naja du hast die Gene von mir, Mathe können wir alle nicht, aber streng dich trotzdem an, dass du durchkommst. Sage ich, eine Ermutigung sieht anders aus. Und wenn wir unsere Mädels schon in der Kita oder in der Vorschule mit Mathe kann ich nicht T-Shirts in die Schule schicken …
Da wird nicht unbedingt der Wunsch nach einem Mathematikstudium draus.
Da ist für mich dann noch lieber dieses die Faust ballen oder wie auch immer. Ich habe dann in meinem Bilderbuch also auch mit großem Vergnügen erzählt die Geschichte von, es gibt diese Postkarte, ich hoffe Sie dürfen das senden, die ein kleines Mädchen zeigt und drunter steht „Mathe ist ein Arschloch“. Wo ich dann gesagt habe, das finde ich gut. Zeigt ein Mädchen beim Matheüben in den Sommerferien und Mathe ist ein Arschloch, das ist eine trotzige Reaktion. Und ich glaube eine trotzige Reaktion ist letztlich auch eine, wo man mit Selbstbewusstsein auf schwierige Probleme losgeht und das ist dann eigentlich schon der sehr viel bessere Zugang und ich würde ja so was nie sagen, weil ich ein höflicher Mensch bin, aber es ist schon ein bisschen manchmal auch mein Zugang zum Mathemachen.
Und es ist einer, mit dem man am Ende eben einfach auch erfolgreich sein kann. Die Probleme sind schwierig, darauf gehen wir los.
Ja man muss sozusagen auch dieses Mysterium, was sich nicht gerne auflösen lassen möchte, ernst nehmen und sozusagen auch als Feind klar markieren und dann sich sozusagen auch dazu entscheiden, dieses Problem dann aber auch anzugehen.
Ja und den Feind soll man dann auch nicht zu klein reden. Das ist ja auch im Fußball keine gute Strategie. Sondern erstens soll es keine Feinde geben beim Fußball, aber es gibt gegnerische Mannschaften und die muss man ernst nehmen und für Mathemachen heißt es letztlich in der 5. Klasse genauso wie in der Wissenschaft, sich einfach mal einzugestehen, das ist hartes Material. Ich habe mal einen Vergleich gelesen, der sagte, Mathe ist wie Diamanten, also hartes Material im Sinne von schwierig, aber eben auch nützlich. Diamanten kann man ja zum Schleifen verwenden und werden dafür gebraucht. Aber es ist eben einfach auch wunderschön. Aber weil es eben so hart ist, muss man es eben einfach auch ernst nehmen.
Und wenn man Matheprobleme lösen will, das ist eben in der 5. Klasse genauso wie wir Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen am Schreibtisch, dann ist das sehr sinnvoll, die Probleme ernst zu nehmen und sich denen zu stellen selbstbewusst und fröhlich.
Bevor wir mit Fußball und anderen Vergleichen in der Abseitsfalle landen, vielleicht noch zuletzt, also wir haben ja jetzt wirklich ein breites Spektrum von inklusionseinschränkenden Parametern aufgestellt, was kann denn der universitäre und wissenschaftliche Bereich da in der Hinsicht noch leisten bzw. was wird da schon geleistet? Weil gerade der Punkt 3 Selbstvertrauen hat ja dann auch eine Menge damit zu tun, wie man auch aufgenommen wird, wie man begleitet wird?
Ja ich glaube das ist ein Bereich der Kommunikation, wo wir aber glaube ich auch stark sind und wo wir uns auch wirklich dann Mühe geben und wo ich glaube dieses Mathe als Wissenschaft machen wir gemeinsam Männer und Frauen schon lange angekommen ist. Insofern ist das kein Thema. Ich bin sehr engagiert in der Berlin Mathematical School, was die gemeinsame Graduiertenschule der drei Berliner Universitäten ist, Exzellenzinitiative und so weiter, wo wir uns schon auch Gedanken machen darüber, wie wir da sozusagen mehr Frauen motivieren können, in dieser Arena von Wissenschaft eben mitzumachen. Und da ist dieses eine der Teil, der am Ende einfach und Konsens ist und eigentlich klar ist, dass man da eine Stimmung und eine Kultur haben will, in der sich alle willkommen fühlen.
Das ist dann auch eine Frage der Kommunikation, also auch mit den Bildern, mit denen man arbeitet, und mit dem Tonfall, mit dem man Leute anspricht, dass das völlig klar ist, dass das sozusagen ein Gemeinsam und Miteinander ist und nicht ein Blöcke gegeneinander Ding. Das wo wir dann eben immer auch nachdenken und arbeiten ist, dann diese organisatorischen Voraussetzungen, die es braucht, um Leute für die Wissenschaft zu gewinnen und in der Wissenschaft zu halten. Und ich glaube, da war vor 30 Jahren auch noch das Bild, was ich eben so aus meinen Studienzeiten kenne, das sagte, wenn man jemand sozusagen Wissenschaft machen will, dann muss er eben 100% Wissenschaft machen, dann heißt es eben einfach auch, erst mal keine Zeit oder zumindest keine Rücksicht auf Familie und so weiter.
Von jemandem, der eine Professur haben will, nimmt man an, dass der eine Postdoczeit im Ausland hier und im Ausland da und wie auch immer und häufige Ortswechsel und so weiter absolviert und nur so kann man Professor werden. Und wenn man dieses Bild sozusagen kultiviert, dann ist es sehr schwierig unter Einklang zu bringen mit Mann und mehrere Kinder oder anderen Familienmodellen und so weiter. Das ist aber die Situation von vor 30 Jahren. Die Situation, so wie ich es heute wahrnehme, eben auch an den Universitäten, ist, dass wir einen Blick dafür bekommen haben, dass Wissenschaft von Menschen gemacht wird und dass es bei Menschen immer individuelle Karriereverläufe gibt. Und wenn jetzt die Frage ist, jemanden willkommen zu heißen oder auch zu beurteilen in der Wissenschaft, dann muss man eben sagen, was hat er oder sie die letzten Jahre gemacht?
Was sind die Nebenbedingungen? Hat er Familie, hat er Kinder? Leute haben ja Auszeiten aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen auch, gesundheitlichen Dingen in Familie. Sozusagen Brüche in Lebensläufen werden inzwischen eben auch nicht als K.O. gesehen, sondern eben letztlich als Dinge, die Lebensläufe interessant machen und so dass man da dann nachfragen muss und am Ende ist eben jemand, der in irgendeiner Hinsicht mehr von der Welt gesehen hat. Jemand, der vielleicht auch für die Wissenschaft besser ist. Und dieses mehr von der Welt gesehen haben heißt jetzt eben nicht unbedingt, drei Postdocjahre in drei unterschiedlichen Ländern an renommierten Universitäten, sondern können eben auch sehr unterschiedliche Aspekte sein. Und insofern sind wir da in einem sehr viel lebendigeren und vielfältigeren Bild von Wissenschaftern und Wissenschaftlerinnen drin und versuchen, das eben auch zu kommunizieren.
Zum Ende würde ich gerne nochmals in die Zukunft blicken. Das macht sich immer ganz gut, wenn man jetzt die Physik anschaut, die haben ja da eine ganze Menge Durchbrüche gefeiert in letzter Zeit. Das Higgs-Boson konnte nachgewiesen werden. Eigentlich laufend neue Erkenntnisse. Gravitationswellen rollen heran. Und man weiß aber auch schon, was sozusagen die nächsten Fragezeichen sind. Dunkle Materie, dunkle Energie. Was ist denn so die dunkle Energie und die dunkle Materie der Mathematik? Was sind denn so die schwarzen Löcher, die noch fallen müssen? Darüber weiß man irgendwie wenig. Was würden Sie denn nächste Woche gern im Netz lesen? Welchen Beweis oder welches unumstößliche Gesetz auf die Seite gekippt wurde?
Ja also bevor ich das sage zwei Bemerkungen. Also erstens, ich gönne den Physikern das. Aber schwarze Löcher und Gravitationswellen sind ja zunächst mal mathematische Strukturen. Und das sind riesige Erfolge für die Mathematik. Wenn die Physiker schwarze Löcher beobachten und Gravitationswellen nachweisen können, die machen das natürlich mit Messapparaten, die auch voller Mathematik sind und so weiter, es sind also Erfolge für die Mathematik.
Ist richtig, gerade bei den Gravitationswellen waren es die mathematischen Modelle, die quasi die Grundlage dafür überhaupt geschaffen haben, diese Messungen durchzuführen.
Genau. Zweite Bemerkung ist, dass das eine Stärke aber auch eine Schwäche von Physik ist, dass es sehr fokussiert ist auf einzelne große Themen. Und ich sage mal so was wie das Higgs-Boson hat uns ja einfach auch Milliarden gekostet, weil man da diese riesigen Experimente dafür braucht und das macht es letztlich notwendig für die Physik eben auch in riesigen Gruppen und alle gemeinsam hinter einem sehr kleinen Teilchen hinterherzurennen, von dem sie gar nicht wissen, ob es das gibt oder nicht.
Macht sich aber immer gut für die Kameras.
Macht sich gut für die Kameras. Für die Mathematik ist das glaube ich auch eine Stärke, dass wir eine riesige Vielfalt von Themen bearbeiten und bearbeiten können und da dann eben auch unsere Erfolge feiern können. Und ich würde ungern jetzt sozusagen die Mathematik so sehr auf einzelne Sachen fokussiert sehen, wie das in Physik automatisch sich tut. Das heißt wir werden die Mathematik des Quantenrechnens, die Mathematik der BigData, des Machine Learnings und so weiter das sind Mathematikbereiche, wo wir riesige Erfolge hatten und haben werden und haben müssen, ohne dass es da jetzt sich sozusagen auf eine Grand Challenge oder eine sozusagen Kernvermutung vielleicht fokussieren lässt.
Anderseits gibt es natürlich auch die großen Meilensteinen und die großen Granitblöcke der Mathematik, die man gerne wegrollen würde. Einer davon ist die sogenannte Riemannsche Hypothese - Bernhard Riemann 1859 glaube ich - die wenn man sie beweisen könnte uns eben sehr viel genauer was über die Verteilung der Primzahlen sagen würde, als wir das bisher können. Also das ist eines der Milleniumprobleme, wo es auch eine Million Dollar darauf ausgesetzt wird. Und wo ich mich wirklich freuen würde, wenn es jemand könnte. Abzusehen ist es nicht. Ein anderes Problem p = np Stephen Cook und andere 1972 ist sozusagen die grundlegende Frage danach, was man eigentlich auf einer Turing-Maschine rechnen kann oder was nicht.
Also die Frage, ob letztlich grundsätzlich jede Art von Problem, die sich schnell verifizieren lässt mit einer geratenen Lösung, auch ohne die geratene Lösung schnell berechnen lässt. Die vermutete Antwort ist nein, beweisen kann es keiner. Auch ein Problem, wo es eine Million Dollar dafür gibt, so ein Clay-Milleniums-Problem???
Nehmen wir doch nur mal an, eins von den beiden, egal welches, wäre jetzt gelöst oder beide, was hätte das dann für Auswirkungen?
Also bei der Riemannschen Hypothese glaube ich, das ist zunächst mal Theorie, das wäre ein Meilenstein in der Zahlentheorie und so weiter. Praktische Auswirkungen glaube ich zunächst mal keine und am Ende kommt es eben doch alles in der Praxis an.
Also ich meine, wenn es um Primzahlen geht, dann ist ja schnell die Kryptografie auch mit berührt.
Wobei in dem Fall ist es nur die Verteilung der Primzahlen. Ich glaube p = np wäre spannender, wenn da jemand wirklich beweisen würde, dass p = np ist, dann würde das sozusagen …
Also die Frage mit ja zu beantworten?
Ja, das würde dann plötzlich heißen, dass eine riesige Klasse von Problemen, von denen wir bisher dachten, sie sind schwer in einem definierten Sinne, nämlich np schwer, eben plötzlich einfach sind, zumindest theoretisch. Und das wäre also eine riesige Revolution, insbesondere wenn die Lösung irgendwie praktisch wäre.
Das heißt da würde sozusagen so ein Tor geöffnet werden, wo man weiß, es lohnt sich, dort durchzumarschieren, weil da ist unter Umständen ein Garten von neuen Erkenntnissen, der sich dadurch überhaupt erst eröffnet?
Ja, ich meine da gehören eben auch unter anderem … Irgendwo in der Ecke von dem Garten sind dann die Verschlüsselungssachen, also sehr viele Verschlüsselungssachen beruhen eben auf so Annahmen, wie der Annahme, dass es zwar einfach ist, zwei lange Zahlen zu multiplizieren. Also was weiß ich fünfhundertstellige Zahlen, gibt eine tausendstellige Zahl. Dass das Faktorisieren aber schwer ist, wobei es einfach wird, wenn ich einem einen Faktor gebe, also sozusagen eine geratene Lösung zu verifizieren ist einfach. Das sind Probleme, die schon im Herzen von moderner Verschlüsselungstechnik liegen, in dem Fall ein Problem, was wieder Quantencomputer können würde. Also da sind wir dann bei sehr aktuellen und sehr relevanten Sachen dabei. Aber vielleicht noch ein drittes Problem, wenn ich es erwähnen darf.
Damit wir wieder bis drei gezählt haben.
Ja eben. Und vielleicht dazu, dass die Frage dann immer ist, ob wir Mathematiker da noch gut genug sind, eben eigentlich Mathematik in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen. Das Kugelpackungsproblem ist ein ganz fundamentales geometrisches Problem.
Das von Kepler, was wir vorhin angesprochen hatten?
Das Kepler-Problem ist die Frage im dreidimensionalen Raum. Ich habe gleich große Kugeln, die ich im Raum packen soll, wie dicht kann ich das machen?
Ist ja auch im Supermarkt dann wichtig, wenn dann wiedermal so alle schätzen sollen, wie viele Kugeln in so einer Tonne drin sind.
Richtig und insofern schon ein praktisches Problem, auch für Kristallstrukturen und so weiter. Das Problem ist nicht mal in der Ebene einfach, wenn die Frage ist, ich habe sozusagen gleich große Münzen, wie viel von der Fläche kann ich da ausfüllen, wenn die nicht überlappen dürfen. Das Problem in Dimension 1-2-3 ist jetzt gelöst. Und dieses Frühjahr hat Marina Wiasofska??? hier in Berlin das Problem gelöst für die Dimensionen 8 und 24. Das ist ein spektakulärer Durchbruch. In diesem Fall wiederum von einer Mathematikerin, die da anderer Leute Dinge natürlich verwendet hat, aber Dinge gesehen hat, die andere Leute nicht gesehen haben. Also eine geniale Lösung, eine ausgesprochen schicke und elegante Lösung.
Offenes Problem wäre aber das Kugelpackungsproblem in Dimension 4. Da gibt es Vermutungen, da gibt es nicht mal einen Ansatz, wie man es löst. Das zeigt vielleicht auch, wie faszinierend Geometrie ist, dass sich da plötzlich Dinge in Dimension 8 tun, die wir aber in Dimension 4 nicht in den Griff bekommen können. Das Problem ist bisher jetzt gelöst in Dimensionen 1, 2, 3, 8 und 24. Also da sieht man faszinierende geometrische Strukturen und jede Menge Rätsel.
Faszinierend sage ich mal. Herr Ziegler vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zu Mathematik und auch der mathematischen Forschung und dem Selbstverständnis im Allgemeinen.
Ich bedanke mich für die Einladung zum Gespräch.
Und vielen Dank auch hier wieder an alle beim Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Ich wünsche allen noch eine gute Zeit bis zum nächsten Gespräch hier bei Forschergeist. Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.